Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The sun was just beginning to rise on Tuesday, January 27, 2009, when Timothy arrived at the Sandy Bay Rowing Club to drop his daughter off for her early morning rowing training. Located immediately south of Hobart's Central Business District, the affluent Waterfront Suburb was home to some of Tasmania's most expensive real estate
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上本期节目的节目说明。2009年1月27日星期二，太阳刚刚升起，蒂莫西（Timothy）抵达桑迪湾赛艇俱乐部（Sandy Bay Rowing Club），送他的女儿去参加清晨的赛艇训练。这个富裕的海滨郊区位于霍巴特中央商务区正南面，拥有塔斯马尼亚州一些最昂贵的房地产，
and was a hotspot for sailing. Timothy parked his car and stepped outside to admire the views of the city and nearby Mount Wellington. As he looked outwards towards the rowing shed, he noticed something bobbing in the water against the rocks. He moved closer and realised it was an inflatable dinghy. The blue and white vessel had the brand name Quicksilver printed on it. Assuming the dinghy must have come undone from its mooring point, Timothy peered inside and noticed that the dinghy's rope was sitting within. This was odd. Had the rope accidentally come undone, he expected it would be trailing in the water. Regardless, Timothy used the rope to
也是帆船运动的热点地区。蒂莫西停好车，走出来欣赏城市和附近惠灵顿山（Mount Wellington）的景色。当他向赛艇棚方向望去时，注意到水里有什么东西在岩石边漂浮。他走近一看，发现那是一艘充气小艇。这艘蓝白相间的船上印着“水银”（Quicksilver）的品牌名称。蒂莫西以为小艇是从系泊点挣脱的，便往里看了看，发现小艇的绳子就在里面。这很奇怪。如果绳子是意外松脱的，他本以为它会拖在水里。无论如何，蒂莫西还是用那根绳子
secure the vessel to a rock. He pointed it out to his daughter's rowing coach Darryl, but they didn't give it much more thought. Timothy joined Darryl in his aluminium speedboat and followed the rowers out for their training session. Just before 7am, the two men were approximately 200 metres from shore when they passed the 53-foot double-mastered yacht named The Four Winds. It was sitting unusually low in the water, especially at its bow. Worried that the yacht might be sinking, the men called the police. Two officers arrived at the shore 15 minutes later to assess the situation. Darryl took one of them out on his speedboat and pulled up alongside the Four Winds.
把船固定在了一块岩石上。他向女儿的赛艇教练达里尔（Darryl）指出了这一点，但他们并没有多想。蒂莫西上了达里尔的铝制快艇，跟随赛艇手们去进行训练。早上7点前不久，两人离岸约200米时，经过了一艘名为“四风号”（The Four Winds）的53英尺双桅帆船。它在水中的吃水异常深，尤其是船头部分。担心游艇可能会沉没，两人报了警。15分钟后，两名警察抵达岸边评估情况。达里尔带着其中一名警察上了他的快艇，并靠在“四风号”旁边。
The officer stepped aboard the upper deck. Leading out from the wheelhouse, the small enclosure that housed the boat's steering wheel, he noticed small splatters of blood. There were also drops of blood on the wheelhouse floor and a small carving knife and blood stained torch near the door. The officer entered the cabin and found it flooded with shin-deep water. The yacht was fitted with water pumps that should have kicked in automatically, but nothing was happening to drain the rapidly filling water. At this rate, it was inevitable that the Four Winds would sink. The police, marine and rescue services were called. By the time they arrived,
警察登上了上层甲板。从驾驶室（即船上放置舵轮的小围栏）出来时，他注意到有少量血迹。驾驶室地板上也有血滴，门边还有一把小雕刻刀和一把沾血的手电筒。警察进入船舱，发现里面积满了没过脚踝的水。游艇上装有应该会自动启动的水泵，但没有任何动静来排出迅速涌入的水。照这样下去，“四风号”沉没是不可避免的。警方、海事和救援部门随即被召集。当他们到达时，
the wheelhouse was significantly flooded and the bow was only one foot above water. The Tasmanian fire service and a salvage agent were called in to try to pump some of the water out to stop the Four Winds from sinking. Authorities phoned the yacht's owners. 55-year-old Sunil Fraser was at home when she received the call about the situation unfolding in Sandy Bay. She was shocked. Her de facto partner, 65-year-old Bob Chappell, had spent the night on their beloved yacht and Sue hadn't heard from him since. The Four Winds had been nothing but trouble for Sue and Bob since they purchased it two months prior. Both experienced sailors, they intended to use it to go traveling when Bob retired in about a
驾驶室已经严重进水，船头离水面仅剩一英尺。塔斯马尼亚消防局和打捞代理人被叫来试图抽走一些水，以阻止“四风号”沉没。当局给游艇的主人打了电话。55岁的苏尼尔·弗雷泽（Sunil Fraser，简称苏）在家中接到了关于桑迪湾正在发生的情况的电话。她感到震惊。她事实上的伴侣，65岁的鲍勃·查佩尔（Bob Chappell），前一天晚上在他们心爱的游艇上过夜，此后苏就再也没有他的消息。自从两个月前购买“四风号”以来，这艘船给苏和鲍勃带来的只有麻烦。作为经验丰富的帆船手，他们打算在鲍勃大约一年后退休时用它去旅行。
year's time. He was the chief physicist of radiology at the W.P. Holman Clinic in the Royal Hobart Hospital, a career he'd proudly spent decades building. While Bob loved his job, he was looking forward to his golden years and the many trips he and Sue planned to take at sea. At the recommendation of their yacht broker, the couple had travelled to Queensland in December to take a look at the Four Winds. They'd immediately fallen in love. Priced at $203,000, it was a bargain for a yacht of its type. A dignified and majestic vessel, it featured a double-mastered catch construction that was perfectly suited to Tasmania's varied weather conditions. It had a white hull with dark timber accents, navy blue sails,
他是皇家霍巴特医院（Royal Hobart Hospital）W.P.霍尔曼诊所（W.P. Holman Clinic）的放射科首席物理学家，这份职业他自豪地耕耘了几十年。虽然鲍勃热爱他的工作，但他很期待自己的晚年生活，以及他和苏计划进行的多次海上航行。在游艇经纪人的推荐下，这对夫妇于12月前往昆士兰查看“四风号”。他们立刻就爱上了它。售价203,000美元，对于这种类型的游艇来说非常划算。这是一艘庄严而宏伟的船只，采用了双桅帆船结构，非常适合塔斯马尼亚多变的天气条件。它有一个白色的船体，配有深色木质装饰，海军蓝色的帆，
and the name Four Winds written along the rear and left-hand side in navy cursive font. At 53 feet long, with approximately 50 square metres of walking space above deck, the yacht was much larger than Bob and Sue were used to sailing. The interior cabin was split into two levels. Four steps below deck led to the wheelhouse, which held the steering wheel and control panels. Three further steps led to the lower saloon level, complete with three bedrooms, a bathroom, kitchen, laundry, and engine room. The bargain price reflected the fact that restorations were needed, but Sue and Bob were ready for the challenge. They hired two crew members to help them sail
船尾和左侧用海军蓝草书字体写着“Four Winds”的名字。船长53英尺，甲板上有约50平方米的行走空间，这艘游艇比鲍勃和苏习惯驾驶的船要大得多。内部船舱分为两层。下甲板四级台阶通向驾驶室，那里有舵轮和控制面板。再下三级台阶通向较低的沙龙层，配有三间卧室、一间浴室、厨房、洗衣房和机舱。便宜的价格反映出它需要翻新，但苏和鲍勃已经准备好迎接挑战。他们雇了两名船员帮助他们驾驶
it down from Queensland to Hobart. This allowed them to familiarise themselves with the boat and test its performance while having professional guidance along the way. However, the voyage was tainted from the start. The day after they set sail, the engine failed as they neared the Gold Coast and they had to be towed to a nearby marina. It turned out that an oyster fungus known as black death had clogged the engine's filters. While repairs were underway, Bob was plagued by increasingly severe nosebleeds. He was admitted to a local hospital, where doctors determined the nosebleeds were caused by Bob's regular consumption of aspirin, which acts as a blood thinner. After some deliberation, it was decided that Sue would
它从昆士兰航行到霍巴特。这使他们能够熟悉这艘船，并在有专业指导的情况下测试其性能。然而，这次航行从一开始就蒙上了阴影。起航后的第二天，当他们接近黄金海岸时，发动机发生故障，他们不得不被拖到附近的码头。事实证明，一种被称为“黑死病”的牡蛎真菌堵塞了发动机的过滤器。在维修期间，鲍勃饱受日益严重的鼻出血困扰。他被送往当地一家医院，医生确定鼻出血是由鲍勃经常服用阿司匹林（一种血液稀释剂）引起的。经过一番商议，决定由苏
continue on with the hired crew members while Bob flew back to Hobart. Once the engine was fixed, Sue and the crew recommenced their journey. Numerous other mechanical problems forced them to stop at various ports for repairs along the way. After 16 days at sea, the four winds finally arrived in Hobart. Bob met the crew at Sandy Bay, where the yacht would be permanently moored. Despite the complicated journey, Sue was excited by the trip and looked forward to many more in the future. Over the following weeks, the couple continued to work on the yacht in their spare time. Bob was somewhat jealous of how well Sue had gotten to know the four winds during the trip from Queensland and was eager to spend more time on board to gain a better understanding of
带着雇来的船员继续航行，而鲍勃则飞回霍巴特。发动机修好后，苏和船员重新开始了旅程。沿途无数其他的机械问题迫使他们在各个港口停靠维修。在海上航行16天后，“四风号”终于抵达霍巴特。鲍勃在桑迪湾与船员会合，游艇将永久停泊在那里。尽管旅途复杂，苏还是对这次旅行感到兴奋，并期待未来有更多的航行。在接下来的几周里，这对夫妇继续在业余时间修理游艇。鲍勃对苏在从昆士兰航行期间对“四风号”的了解程度感到有些嫉妒，并渴望花更多时间在船上，以更好地了解
how it worked. Monday, January 26 was the Australia Day public holiday and the couple spent the morning on the yacht. Bob tinkered about in the engine room while Sue tidied up. At around midday, she used their blue and white Quicksilver dinghy to travel back to shore to have lunch with Bob's sister Anne, who was visiting from Sydney. When Sue returned to the yacht at around 230, Bob was in a bad mood. He had isolated an engine leak and wanted to stay on board overnight to continue working on it. Sue didn't think this was a good idea. It was a windy, overcast afternoon and the water was choppy. Furthermore, she would have to take their dinghy to get back to shore, meaning Bob wouldn't have access to it overnight. She urged Bob to reconsider,
它是如何运作的。1月26日星期一是澳大利亚国庆日公共假期，这对夫妇在游艇上度过了上午。鲍勃在机舱里修修补补，苏则在整理。中午左右，她用他们蓝白相间的“水银”小艇回到岸上，与鲍勃从悉尼来访的妹妹安妮（Anne）共进午餐。当苏在2点半左右回到游艇时，鲍勃心情不好。他发现了一个发动机泄漏点，想在船上过夜继续修理。苏认为这不是个好主意。那天下午风很大，阴天，水面波涛汹涌。此外，她必须用他们的小艇回岸，这意味着鲍勃晚上将无法使用它。她敦促鲍勃重新考虑，
but he checked the charts and was confident that the wind would subside. Sue eventually agreed. After all, the yacht was stocked with food and emergency supplies, so surely Bob would be okay if something unforeseen arose. He was also a strong swimmer who would have no trouble swimming to safety in case of an emergency. Bob didn't have a mobile phone, so Sue gave him hers in case he needed to contact her on their landline throughout the evening. She then took the dinghy back to shore, tying it to a ladder at the Royal Yacht Club. Just after 7 the following morning, Sue called her mobile to check on Bob. There was no answer. Moments later, she received a call from police to inform her that the four winds
但他查看了海图，确信风会平息。苏最终同意了。毕竟，游艇上储备了食物和应急物资，所以如果发生不可预见的情况，鲍勃肯定会没事的。他也是个游泳健将，如果发生紧急情况，游到安全地带应该没问题。鲍勃没有手机，所以苏把她的手机给了他，以防他晚上需要通过他们的座机联系她。然后她乘小艇回到岸上，把它系在皇家游艇俱乐部的梯子上。第二天早上7点刚过，苏拨打她的手机查看鲍勃的情况。没有人接听。片刻之后，她接到警方的电话，通知她“四风号”
was sinking. Sue immediately drove down to Meraville Esplanade, which overlooked Sandy Bay and met the police on the shore. She was soon joined by her two daughters and Bob's son. They watched on as emergency crews worked for over an hour to determine the source of the yacht's leak. It turned out that a 75mm pipe near the toilet had been cut, allowing water to flow freely into the vessel. The Seacock was also open. This is a valve that permits water to flow in and out of the boat. It's typically left closed when not in use. Whoever had cut the pipe and opened the Seacock likely had intimate knowledge of the yacht, as these items were hidden away and their function wouldn't be clear to a novice. With these problems finally identified, the four winds
正在下沉。苏立即开车前往俯瞰桑迪湾的梅里维尔海滨大道（Meraville Esplanade），并在岸边见到了警察。不久，她的两个女儿和鲍勃的儿子也加入了她的行列。他们看着救援人员工作了一个多小时，试图确定游艇泄漏的来源。结果发现，厕所附近的一根75毫米管道被切断，导致水自由流入船内。通海阀（Seacock）也被打开了。这是一种允许水流入和流出船只的阀门。不使用时通常保持关闭。无论谁切断了管道并打开了通海阀，都可能对游艇非常了解，因为这些物品隐藏在里面，新手不会明白它们的功能。随着这些问题终于被查明，“四风号”
was successfully salvaged. The question remained, where was Bob Chapel? Police conducted a full search of the yacht and quickly determined Bob was not on board. A grid search of the surrounding waters also failed to uncover any signs of the 65-year-old. While examining the four winds, police noticed more blood splatters on the lounge suite in the saloon. At the lowest point of the hull, the automatic bilge pump had also been deactivated. This pump is designed to empty any excess water into the ocean to prevent a vessel from sinking. The four winds bilge pump was fitted with an alarm, which was supposed to sound if water reached a certain level. This too had been deactivated.
被成功打捞。问题依然存在，鲍勃·查佩尔在哪里？警方对游艇进行了全面搜查，很快确定鲍勃不在船上。对周围水域的网格化搜索也未能发现这位65岁老人的任何踪迹。在检查“四风号”时，警方注意到沙龙的沙发套上有更多的血迹。在船体最低处，自动舱底泵也被关闭了。该泵旨在将多余的水排入海洋，以防止船只沉没。四风号的舱底泵装有警报器，如果水位达到一定高度，警报器应该会响。这个警报器也被关闭了。
With all these factors combined, it was clear that the yacht had been deliberately tampered with. A local man was walking his dog along Maryville Esplanade when he noticed a red yachting jacket with grey trim. It was hanging on a low brick fence outside a residential property on the corner of Margaret Street. Aware of the chaos on the waterfront, he left the jacket untouched and walked to the beach to inform the police. An officer went to question the occupants of the property, who said the red jacket wasn't theirs. They'd arrived home at around six the previous evening and hadn't noticed the jacket then, so it must have been placed there recently. When Sue returned to the scene, she was shown
综合所有这些因素，很明显游艇被人蓄意破坏了。一名当地男子在梅里维尔海滨大道遛狗时，注意到一件带有灰色饰边的红色游艇夹克。它挂在玛格丽特街拐角处一处住宅外的低矮砖墙上。意识到海滨的混乱，他没有触碰夹克，而是走到海滩通知警察。一名警官去询问该房产的住户，他们说那件红夹克不是他们的。他们前一天晚上6点左右到家，当时没注意到这件夹克，所以它一定是最近才被放在那里的。当苏回到现场时，她被展示了
the jacket and asked whether it belonged to her. She said she'd never seen it before, stating, it wasn't from the yacht. Officers began door-knocking homes along Maryville Esplanade for information. They also checked records of nearby pay phones and contacted local bus and taxi companies, but no useful leads emerged. Bob's whereabouts remained unknown. Just before midday, an officer visited Sue at home to take an official statement. Sue described her relationship with Bob as healthy with no major problems. The couple had met in 1989 through mutual friends and had immediately hit it off.
这件夹克，并被问及它是否属于她。她说她以前从未见过它，并称：“它不是游艇上的。”警官开始在梅里维尔海滨大道沿线的住户家敲门询问信息。他们还检查了附近公用电话的记录，并联系了当地的公交和出租车公司，但没有出现有用的线索。鲍勃的下落仍然不明。中午前不久，一名警官到苏的家中录正式口供。苏描述她与鲍勃的关系很健康，没有重大问题。这对夫妇于1989年通过共同的朋友认识，并一见钟情。
They had a lot in common. Both had migrated to Australia from the UK and grown up in Victoria. Eventually moving to Tasmania. They were both divorced with adult children from their previous marriages. Both intellectuals, they shared a love of books, gourmet food and the outdoors, as well as an interest in current affairs. They enjoyed having deep conversations and liked to debate their differing opinions. Although they had contrasting personalities, Sue's extraversion complemented Bob's reserved nature. Sue told the officer about Bob's recent ill health and recurring nosebleeds. She explained that Bob didn't have access to their dinghy if he needed it to leave the yacht in
他们有很多共同点。两人都是从英国移民到澳大利亚，并在维多利亚州长大。最终搬到了塔斯马尼亚。他们都离过婚，且与前任配偶育有成年子女。两人都是知识分子，都热爱书籍、美食和户外活动，也对时事感兴趣。他们喜欢进行深入的交谈，也喜欢辩论彼此不同的观点。虽然他们性格迥异，但苏的外向弥补了鲍勃内向的性格。苏向警官讲述了鲍勃最近的健康状况不佳和反复出现的鼻出血。她解释说，如果鲍勃晚上需要离开游艇，他无法使用他们的小艇，但由于他的年龄，他无论如何都无法独自上下小艇。至于通海阀和舱底泵，苏不知道有什么问题。她和鲍勃经常检查它们，以确保一切正常。如果有人为了伤害鲍勃而蓄意破坏它们，苏想不出任何可能的罪魁祸首。鲍勃没有已知的敌人，也没有人会想伤害他。当被问及她前一天下午的行踪时，苏说她在3点到3点半之间回到岸上。然后她开车去了当地的邦宁斯仓库（Bunnings Warehouse）五金店，在那里逛了几个小时，然后什么也没买就离开了。
the night, but due to his age he was unable to get in and out of the dinghy on his own anyway. As for the Seacock and Bilge pump, Sue wasn't aware of any problems. She and Bob checked them both often to ensure everything was in working order. If anyone had deliberately tampered with them in an effort to harm Bob, Sue couldn't think of any likely culprits. Bob had no known enemies and there was no one who would want to hurt him. When asked about her movements the previous afternoon, Sue said she arrived back to shore sometime between 3 and 3.30. She then drove to the local Bunnings Warehouse hardware store, where she browsed the aisles for several hours before leaving without buying anything.
（注：此段落与前文有重复，已根据原文逻辑翻译）
By the time she got home it was already dark. It was a relatively uneventful evening until just after 10 when the phone rang. On the other line was Richard King, a friend of one of Bob's daughters. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to her as Lisa. Richard was worried. Lisa suffered from mental health issues that included paranoia and delusions. Although she hadn't seen her father in a year, she had recently become increasingly concerned about his health as well as the safety of his yacht. Richard told Sue that Lisa was convinced something bad was going to happen to Bob. She wanted to go down to the Bay to check that his yacht was safe. Lisa had also threatened to take her own life and Richard was
当她回到家时，天已经黑了。这是一个相对平静的夜晚，直到10点刚过电话响了。电话那头是理查德·金（Richard King），鲍勃女儿的朋友。为了清楚起见，案件档案将称她为丽莎（Lisa）。理查德很担心。丽莎患有心理健康问题，包括偏执和妄想。虽然她已经一年没见过她父亲了，但她最近越来越担心他的健康以及他游艇的安全。理查德告诉苏，丽莎确信鲍勃会出事。她想去海湾检查他的游艇是否安全。丽莎还威胁要自杀，理查德很
worried she would go through with it. Although Sue took his concerns seriously, she remained calm. Lisa had threatened suicide in the past but had never acted on it. She also didn't know the name of the four wins or where it was moored, so it was unlikely she would go out on her own to try and find it. After speaking for around half an hour, Richard and Sue were satisfied that Lisa would be okay. Still, Sue later wake that night worried about what Richard had told her. She eventually dozed off and when she woke up, she discovered that Lisa's concerns about Bob were right. Detectives took Sue on board the four wins which had been towed to a dock in Hobart to see if she could identify anything out of the ordinary. She started noticing things right away.
担心她会真的这么做。虽然苏认真对待他的担忧，但她保持冷静。丽莎过去曾威胁过自杀，但从未付诸行动。她也不知道“四风号”的名字或停泊地点，所以她不太可能独自出去寻找它。在交谈了大约半小时后，理查德和苏确信丽莎会没事的。尽管如此，苏那天晚上后来醒来，担心理查德告诉她的事情。她最终睡着了，当她醒来时，发现丽莎对鲍勃的担忧是对的。侦探们带着苏上了“四风号”（已被拖到霍巴特的一个码头），看看她能否识别出任何异常情况。她立刻注意到了一些事情。
The switches on the fuse board were in the incorrect position. A green rope on the deck was in disarray and not in its usual spot. Significant lengths of rope were also missing, especially from the main mast. A red winch handle which is used to adjust rope tension and was usually stored in a locker at the back of the boat had been inserted into the winch on the main mast. A rope around the winch had also been cut and another was lying out of place in a pile on the deck. The wood around the yacht's rear entry hatch was marked with rope burn. There were also some loose carpet panels in the main saloon. Sue explained these couldn't come loose by accident, they could only be lifted by removing mini screws.
保险丝板上的开关位置不对。甲板上的一根绿色绳子乱七八糟，不在它通常的位置。大量的绳子也不见了，尤其是主桅杆上的。一个红色的绞盘手柄（用于调节绳索张力，通常存放在船后的储物柜中）被插入了主桅杆上的绞盘中。绞盘周围的一根绳子也被切断了，另一根绳子乱七八糟地堆在甲板上。游艇后入口舱口周围的木头上留下了绳子摩擦的痕迹。主沙龙里还有一些松动的地毯板。苏解释说，这些不可能意外松动，只能通过拆除微型螺丝才能掀开。
Entering the main cabin, Sue saw that a heavy fire extinguisher was missing from its bracket. Outside the wheelhouse, the emergency position indicating radio beacon, known as an E-PURB, was also missing. Part of its bracket had been snapped off and fallen to the ground. Bob knew the E-PURB was easily removed from the bracket by simply pulling it up, so it was unlikely he was the one who broke it. The device was found hours later by a passerby walking along the beach. Several latent fingerprints were identified on it and ran through the national database, but there was no match and the item revealed nothing else of significance.
进入主船舱，苏看到一个沉重的灭火器从支架上不见了。在驾驶室外，应急位置指示无线电信标（E-PURB）也不见了。它的支架部分被折断并掉在地上。鲍勃知道E-PURB只需向上拉就能轻松从支架上取下，所以他不太可能是弄坏它的人。该设备几小时后被一名路过海滩的行人发现。上面鉴定出几个潜在指纹，并与国家数据库进行了比对，但没有匹配结果，该物品也没有显示出任何其他重要信息。
Although Sue had been advised not to touch anything, she began playing with switches on the electrical panel until the bilge pump alarm sounded. She pointed out that the alarm was so loud, residents of the neighboring suburb would have woken up if it had gone off the previous evening. She also pointed out a torch and empty juice container which didn't belong on the yacht. But these were confirmed to have been absentmindedly left behind by police. Police divers searched Sandy Bay where the yacht was initially moored, covering a circular space approximately 100 meters in diameter. Although visibility was good, they still didn't find any sign of Bob Chappell.
虽然苏被建议不要触碰任何东西，但她开始拨弄电气面板上的开关，直到舱底泵警报器响起。她指出，警报声非常大，如果前一天晚上响过，邻近郊区的居民肯定会被吵醒。她还指出了一个不属于游艇的手电筒和空果汁容器。但这些被证实是警察无意中留下的。警方潜水员搜查了“四风号”最初停泊的桑迪湾，覆盖了一个直径约100米的圆形区域。虽然能见度很好，但他们仍然没有发现鲍勃·查佩尔的任何踪迹。
The search continued the following day, January 28. Police divers re-entered the waters, but they lost visibility upon reaching a depth of 23 meters. Unable to see the ocean floor, they abandoned the search. Tests confirmed the blood on the wheelhouse floor, steps, torch and lounge suite had come from Bob. Although it couldn't be determined how long the blood had been there, the two crew members who had helped sail the yacht from Queensland had cleaned the boat thoroughly upon their arrival to Hobart. They didn't recall seeing any blood stains at the time, deeming it unlikely that the blood was left over from Bob's nosebleeds. Fingerprints were also uncovered throughout the
搜查在第二天1月28日继续进行。警方潜水员再次进入水域，但他们在达到23米深度时失去了能见度。由于无法看到海底，他们放弃了搜查。测试证实，驾驶室地板、台阶、手电筒和沙发套上的血迹来自鲍勃。虽然无法确定血迹存在了多久，但那两名帮助将游艇从昆士兰航行到霍巴特的船员在抵达霍巴特后彻底清洁了船只。他们不记得当时看到任何血迹，认为血迹是鲍勃鼻出血留下的可能性不大。指纹也在整个
yacht. Most belonged to recent passengers, including the two crewmates who travelled with Sue down from Queensland and Bob's son, Timothy. There were also several other unidentified fingerprints. A strand of female hair was found near the skylight hatch and another at the bottom of the wheelhouse steps. Then, there was a dinner plate-sized stain found on the yacht, believed to have been vomited, urine or saliva. It tested positive for female DNA. Neither the stain nor the hairs were found to have originated from Sue or her daughters. Whoever the source was, she was unknown to police. A small blue face washer and two wet rags covered in brown stains that appeared to be vomit, were also recovered and taken for further analysis.
游艇上被发现。大多数属于最近的乘客，包括与苏一起从昆士兰航行下来的两名船员和鲍勃的儿子蒂莫西。还有几个其他未识别的指纹。在天窗舱口附近发现了一根女性头发，在驾驶室台阶底部发现了另一根。此外，游艇上还发现了一块餐盘大小的污渍，被认为是呕吐物、尿液或唾液。它检测出女性DNA呈阳性。无论是污渍还是头发，都被发现并非来自苏或她的女儿们。无论来源是谁，警方都不知道。一块蓝色小面巾和两块沾满褐色污渍（看起来像是呕吐物）的湿抹布也被找回，并送去进行进一步分析。
The possibility that Bob took his own life was ultimately ruled out. He had no idea his own life was ultimately ruled out. He hadn't undergone any behavioural changes recently, including showing signs of depression. It was the opposite. He'd been overseeing a major project at work that he wanted to complete and was excited about his plans for the future. Based on the evidence so far uncovered, it was much more likely that Bob had met with foul play. The most likely scenario was that the assailant had used the quick silver dinghy Sue had tied up at the Royal Yacht Club to get to and from the Four Winds. Once on board, they might have torn the heavy fire extinguisher from its bracket and used it to bludgeon Bob to death in the saloon.
鲍勃自杀的可能性最终被排除。他最近没有任何行为改变，包括表现出抑郁迹象。恰恰相反。他一直在监督工作中的一个重大项目，他想完成该项目，并对未来的计划感到兴奋。根据目前发现的证据，鲍勃更有可能遭遇了谋杀。最可能的情况是，袭击者使用了苏系在皇家游艇俱乐部的“水银”小艇往返于“四风号”。一旦上船，他们可能从支架上扯下沉重的灭火器，并在沙龙里用它将鲍勃殴打致死。
Several carpet squares were missing and it was possible these had been removed from the boat to destroy evidence. Bob's body, which weighed 64 kilograms, might have then been tied with rope and dragged up the stairs using the winch before being dumped overboard. The killer then used the dinghy to return to shore, dumping it on the beach without tying it up. Investigators conducted various experiments to test their theory. Although their approach wasn't very scientific, they confirmed that the winch was capable of hoisting a man of Bob's weight from the side of the missing carpet squares. Based on the yacht's specifications and the volume of water flowing in when it was discovered sinking, a naval engineer determined it would
几块地毯不见了，这可能是为了销毁证据而从船上移走的。鲍勃体重64公斤，可能被绳子捆住，用绞盘拖上楼梯，然后被扔进海里。凶手随后使用小艇回到岸上，将其扔在海滩上而没有系好。调查人员进行了各种实验来测试他们的理论。虽然他们的方法不是很科学，但他们证实绞盘有能力将鲍勃体重的人从缺失地毯的侧面吊起。根据游艇的规格和被发现下沉时流入的水量，海军工程师确定，如果管道和通海阀同时被切断，
take approximately 9 to 12 hours for the boat to sink had both the pipe and seacock been cut at the same time. Given that the yacht was at its lowest point in the water at around 8 o'clock on the morning of January 27, it was estimated that the Four Winds had likely been sabotaged around midnight. Investigators were left to determine who would want to hurt Bob Chapel and why. Outside of work, Bob mostly kept to himself. A typical evening for Bob involved a relaxing drink, cooking a nice meal and settling in with a good book. This was not the routine of a man who sought trouble. Sue was of the opinion that trouble had instead found Bob. Just 13 days before Bob went missing, Sue believed someone had tried to break into the Four Winds.
船只大约需要9到12小时才会沉没。鉴于游艇在1月27日早上8点左右处于水中最低点，估计“四风号”很可能是在午夜左右被蓄意破坏的。调查人员不得不确定谁会想伤害鲍勃·查佩尔以及为什么。在工作之外，鲍勃大多独来独往。鲍勃典型的夜晚包括喝杯放松的酒，做顿美餐，然后读一本好书。这不是一个自找麻烦的人的作风。苏认为麻烦反而找到了鲍勃。在鲍勃失踪前仅13天，苏认为有人试图闯入“四风号”。
She had boarded the yacht to find that the electrical switchboard and freshwater pump cover were open and the chart table had been accessed. It wasn't the first time. While the Four Winds was being repaired in Queensland, the mechanic had advised Sue that the yacht had been broken into and several panels had been opened and moved about. Sue had noted that a similar looking yacht had recently been used to smuggle drugs into Australia. Consequently, she wondered whether someone might have planted drugs in the Four Winds during the journey down from Queensland. When the smuggler or their cohorts went to collect the goods in Tasmania, they would have unexpectedly found Bob on board and could have killed him to
她登上游艇发现电气配电盘和淡水泵盖是打开的，海图桌也被动过。这不是第一次了。当“四风号”在昆士兰维修时，机械师曾告诉苏，游艇被闯入过，几个面板被打开并移动过。苏注意到一艘看起来相似的游艇最近被用来向澳大利亚走私毒品。因此，她怀疑是否有人在从昆士兰航行下来的过程中在“四风号”上藏了毒品。当走私者或其同伙去塔斯马尼亚取货时，他们可能意外地发现鲍勃在船上，并可能杀了他以
cover their tracks. Sue seemed convinced this was the likely outcome and had been urging police to follow up on this line of investigation from the very beginning. Within minutes of arriving on the scene to find the yacht sinking, she'd mentioned this possibility to a constable. She told police that several other boats in the Sandy Bay area had recently been broken into or tampered with. Prior to Bob's disappearance, she noticed a vessel on the water with the license plate beginning with PV. Sue immediately noted this as suspicious. She believed this indicated that the boat was from Port Villa, a harbourside city in Vanuatu that was a known hotspot for drug smuggling. Sniffer dogs taken on board the Four Winds were unable to detect traces of drugs
掩盖他们的踪迹。苏似乎确信这是最可能的结果，并从一开始就一直敦促警方跟进这条调查线索。在到达现场发现游艇下沉后的几分钟内，她就向一名警员提到了这种可能性。她告诉警方，桑迪湾地区的其他几艘船最近也被闯入或篡改过。在鲍勃失踪前，她注意到水面上有一艘船，车牌以PV开头。苏立即认为这很可疑。她认为这表明该船来自瓦努阿图的港口城市维拉港（Port Villa），那里是众所周知的毒品走私热点。带上“四风号”的嗅探犬无法检测到毒品痕迹，
due to severe water damage to the yacht's interior. Police were also unable to confirm whether a boat from Port Villa had recently been in the Sandy Bay area. Weeks passed without any sign of Bob Chapel. He didn't access his bank accounts or make contact with any of his loved ones, leading to the conclusion he was likely deceased. The limited forensic evidence recovered on board the Four Winds had led nowhere. The red yachting jacket found on the corner of Margaret Street and Maryville Esplanade wasn't thought to be relevant to Bob's case, as Sue said she had never seen it before. Investigators had it tested anyway. If anything, they hoped forensics might point towards its owner and give them a solid lead as to who might have been in the area on the night
因为游艇内部受到严重水损。警方也无法证实维拉港的船只最近是否在桑迪湾地区。几周过去了，没有任何鲍勃·查佩尔的踪迹。他没有使用银行账户，也没有联系任何亲人，导致结论是他很可能已经死亡。在“四风号”上发现的有限法医证据毫无进展。在玛格丽特街和梅里维尔海滨大道拐角处发现的红色游艇夹克被认为与鲍勃的案件无关，因为苏说她以前从未见过它。调查人员还是对其进行了测试。如果说有什么的话，他们希望法医能指向它的主人，并给他们提供一条可靠的线索，说明谁可能在那个晚上出现在该地区。
Bob went missing. Swabs taken from the inner surfaces of the cuffs and collar were tested for DNA and returned a match. The jacket had been worn by none other than Sue Neil Fraser. This wasn't the only lie that Sue had been caught in. As investigators spoke with people who had been at Sandy Bay on January 26, it became clear that something wasn't adding up. Just before four that afternoon, a group of men arrived at the Royal Yacht Club marina. They noticed the Four Winds offshore and recalled a grey mid-sized dinghy tied to the vessel. It was bobbing up and down in the choppy sea, taking in some water. They recalled the dinghy as worn and faded, with scuff marks and
鲍勃失踪了。从袖口和领子内侧提取的拭子进行了DNA测试，并返回了匹配结果。这件夹克的主人正是苏·尼尔·弗雷泽（Sue Neil Fraser）。这并不是苏被揭穿的唯一谎言。当调查人员与1月26日在桑迪湾的人交谈时，很明显有些事情不对劲。那天下午4点前不久，一群人抵达皇家游艇俱乐部码头。他们注意到离岸的“四风号”，并回忆起一艘灰色的中型小艇系在船上。它在波涛汹涌的海面上上下起伏，进了一些水。他们回忆起这艘小艇破旧褪色，有磨损痕迹和
a grey leecloth, a piece of fabric that acts as a safety net. Another witness who had been sitting on a nearby jetty at around 5pm also recalled the dinghy alongside the Four Winds. They saw an elderly man pottering about on the yacht, which struck them as odd. They wondered why someone would choose to be on a moored boat in such turbulent waters. These recollections contradicted the statement provided by Sue Neil Fraser. She had told police that she had travelled from the Four Winds to the beach, arriving at the shore between 3 and 3.30pm. According to witnesses, the dinghy was still floating alongside the Four Winds between 4 and 5pm. Furthermore, according to his son, Bob was very safety conscious. It was therefore strange that he would choose to stay on the
一个灰色的防浪布（一种充当安全网的织物）。另一名下午5点左右坐在附近码头上的目击者也回忆起“四风号”旁边的小艇。他们看到一位老人在游艇上忙碌，这让他们觉得很奇怪。他们想知道为什么有人会选择在如此动荡的水域停泊的船上。这些回忆与苏·尼尔·弗雷泽提供的陈述相矛盾。她告诉警方，她从“四风号”乘船到海滩，在下午3点到3点半之间到达岸边。据目击者称，小艇在下午4点到5点之间仍漂浮在“四风号”旁边。此外，据他儿子说，鲍勃非常有安全意识。因此，他选择留在
yacht without the dinghy in case of an emergency. Sue had told police that Bob was unable to get in and out of the dinghy without assistance anyway, so there was no issue in leaving him without access to it. Bob's son disputed this. He'd seen his father operate the dinghy before without any problems. Following up on Sue's claims that she'd visited Bunnings Warehouse after reaching land, police checked the store's CCTV footage. At no point was Sue or her car captured on the premises. Sue claimed to have arrived at Bunnings around 4.40pm and spent several hours browsing the aisles, but this wasn't possible. Given that January 26 had been the Australia Day public holiday, the store had shut early at 6pm, rather than its usual closing time of 9pm.
游艇上而不留小艇以备紧急情况是很奇怪的。苏曾告诉警方，鲍勃无论如何都无法在没有帮助的情况下上下小艇，所以让他没有小艇使用并没有问题。鲍勃的儿子对此表示异议。他以前见过他父亲操作小艇，没有任何问题。为了跟进苏关于她在到达陆地后访问邦宁斯仓库的说法，警方检查了商店的闭路电视录像。苏或她的车在任何时候都没有出现在该场所。苏声称她在下午4点40分左右到达邦宁斯，并花了几个小时浏览过道，但这不可能。鉴于1月26日是澳大利亚国庆日公共假期，商店在下午6点提前关门，而不是通常的晚上9点。
Sue maintained she'd been home all night. Police checked her phone records and confirmed she had received a call from Richard, the man who voiced his concerns about Bob's daughter Lisa, at 10.05pm, as stated. Richard told police that Sue sounded relaxed and normal during their phone conversation, not like she had anything to hide. Sue said she went to bed after her call with Richard. At 11.30pm, a man was observing the ocean from his parked car near the Sandy Bay Royal Yacht Club Sheds. He'd stopped by the bay to unwind and found the area completely deserted. All of a sudden, his attention was drawn to the sound of an outboard motor. Out on the water was an inflatable dinghy. It was too dark to confirm the colour,
苏坚持说她整晚都在家。警方检查了她的电话记录，证实她确实在晚上10点05分接到了理查德（那个对鲍勃女儿丽莎表示担忧的男人）的电话，正如所说。理查德告诉警方，苏在电话交谈中听起来很放松、很正常，不像有什么要隐瞒的。苏说她在与理查德通话后就上床睡觉了。晚上11点30分，一名男子从他停在桑迪湾皇家游艇俱乐部棚屋附近的车里观察海洋。他停在海湾边放松，发现该地区完全荒无人烟。突然，他的注意力被舷外马达的声音吸引了。水面上有一艘充气小艇。天太黑了，无法确认颜色，
but the man could make the outline of a person piloting the vessel. Based on their silhouette, it looked to be a woman. The dinghy was heading in the direction of the four winds, and the man soon lost sight of it. Almost an hour later, at 12.15am, CCTV footage from an ATM surveillance camera 800m from the Royal Yacht Club captured a grey Ford Falcon station wagon driving past the area. This was the same kind of car that Sue Neil Fraser drove. When shown the footage, even Sue's daughters conceded that it looked like their mother's car. The vehicle's number plate wasn't captured in the footage, so it couldn't be said with certainty
但这名男子能看出驾驶船只的人的轮廓。根据他们的剪影，看起来像是一个女人。小艇正朝着“四风号”的方向驶去，该男子很快就失去了它的踪影。近一个小时后，即凌晨12点15分，距离皇家游艇俱乐部800米处的一台ATM监控摄像头捕捉到一辆灰色福特猎鹰（Ford Falcon）旅行车驶过该地区。这正是苏·尼尔·弗雷泽驾驶的那种车。当看到录像时，连苏的女儿们也承认这看起来像她们母亲的车。车辆的车牌没有被录像捕捉到，所以不能肯定地说
who the car belonged to. Then, at 3.08am, another call appeared on Sue's home phone records. It had been placed to Star 10 Hash, an automated service that identifies the last unanswered call received by a landline. Not only had Sue lied about not making any further phone calls after speaking to Richard, the Star 10 Hash call raised a more important question. Why was Sue wanting to know if anyone had called her in the middle of the night? Was it because she had left the house and wanted to make sure that nobody had called and discovered she was out during this time frame? At 7.04am, on the morning of January 27, Sue had called her mobile phone, which she had left on board with Bob.
这辆车属于谁。然后，在凌晨3点08分，苏的家庭电话记录中出现了另一个电话。它是拨给“星10井号”（Star 10 Hash）的，这是一个自动服务，可以识别座机收到的最后一个未接来电。苏不仅撒谎说在与理查德通话后没有再打过任何电话，“星10井号”电话还提出了一个更重要的问题。为什么苏想知道半夜是否有人给她打过电话？是因为她离开了家，想确保没有人打过电话并发现她在那段时间外出吗？1月27日早上7点04分，苏拨打了她留在船上与鲍勃在一起的手机。
When questioned, Sue said she was calling the yacht to check in on Bob. As for the Star 10 Hash, she had no recollection of ever placing the call. Sue had been very quick to push the drug smuggling theory, claiming that several boats in the area had recently been broken into. Police checked their records from the previous three months and couldn't find any evidence to support this. No other break-ins had been reported, including the one that allegedly took place on board the four wins. Furthermore, when an officer had first gone to Sue's house to take down an official statement on the day Bob was discovered missing, they noticed something odd.
当被问及时，苏说她是在给游艇打电话查看鲍勃的情况。至于“星10井号”，她不记得打过那个电话。苏非常急于推行毒品走私理论，声称该地区的几艘船最近被闯入过。警方检查了他们过去三个月的记录，找不到任何证据支持这一点。没有报告其他闯入事件，包括据称发生在“四风号”上的那起。此外，当一名警官第一天去苏家录正式口供时，他们注意到了一些奇怪的事情。
Sue's left wrist was strapped up and there was a band-aid on her thumb. Sue explained the wrist injury was from an old boating incident which flared up occasionally. The officer asked Sue to remove her band-aid. She complied, revealing a laceration approximately one to two centimetres long. Sue claimed she'd accidentally cut herself, but didn't elaborate further. At the time, the interviewing officer hadn't thought too much of it. That was until several weeks later when he happened to catch a glimpse of something that stirred his memory. On January 26, Sue had left the four wins around midday to have lunch with Bob's sister, Ann. During the meal, Ann had taken some photos. The officer chanced upon them.
苏的左手腕缠着绷带，拇指上贴着创可贴。苏解释说手腕受伤是由于一次旧的划船事故，偶尔会复发。警官要求苏取下创可贴。她照做了，露出一道大约一到两厘米长的伤口。苏声称她不小心割伤了自己，但没有详细说明。当时，采访的警官并没有多想。直到几周后，他偶然瞥见了一些勾起他记忆的东西。1月26日，苏在中午左右离开“四风号”，与鲍勃的妹妹安妮共进午餐。用餐期间，安妮拍了一些照片。警官偶然发现了它们。
He took a closer look at Sue's wrist. There was no bandage, nor was there any sign of a cut or band-aid on her thumb. This meant Sue had sustained the injuries sometime between having lunch with Ann and when the officer interviewed her in the wake of Bob's disappearance less than 24 hours later. Could it have been during the course of an attack or an attempt to dispose of Bob's body? The truth was, police had been viewing Sue with suspicion from the outset of the investigation. When she first arrived at Sandy Bay on January 27 after being informed that her yacht was sinking, she didn't appear overly distressed about the situation. At no point did she ask about Bob's well-being. When speaking about Bob in subsequent police
他仔细看了看苏的手腕。没有绷带，拇指上也没有割伤或创可贴的迹象。这意味着苏是在与安妮共进午餐和鲍勃失踪后不到24小时警官采访她之间的时间里受的伤。这可能是在袭击过程中或试图处理鲍勃尸体时发生的吗？事实是，警方从调查一开始就对苏持怀疑态度。当她在1月27日得知游艇下沉后首次抵达桑迪湾时，她对这种情况似乎并不感到过度痛苦。她从未询问过鲍勃的健康状况。在随后的警方
interviews, she kept referring to him in the past tense, as though she already knew he was no longer alive. Sue apologised for this, explaining she'd already come to terms with the fact that Bob was most likely deceased. Investigators weren't convinced. With all this in mind, they pieced together a possible scenario based on Sue's guilt. After her call with Richard, Sue drove her forward to Sandy Bay, donned the red yachting jacket, and took the quick silver dinghy out to the yacht. She either bludgeoned or starved Bob to death before using ropes and a winch to transport his body out of the saloon onto the deck and into the dinghy. From there, she used a heavy object, most likely the yacht's fire extinguisher,
采访中谈到鲍勃时，她一直用过去时态称呼他，就好像她已经知道他不再活着了。苏为此道歉，解释说她已经接受了鲍勃很可能已经死亡的事实。调查人员并不信服。考虑到所有这些，他们根据苏的罪行拼凑出了一个可能的情景。在与理查德通话后，苏开车前往桑迪湾，穿上红色游艇夹克，乘“水银”小艇前往游艇。她要么殴打要么勒死了鲍勃，然后用绳子和绞盘将他的尸体从沙龙运到甲板上，再运到小艇里。从那里，她使用重物（很可能是游艇的灭火器）
to weigh Bob's body down and throw him overboard. It was some time during this process that she injured her wrist and cut her thumb. Using her knowledge of the four winds inner workings, Sue then cut the pipe, turned on the seacock, and deactivated the bilge pump and alarms in a bid to sink the yacht and destroy evidence. A mechanic who had worked on the boat in early January confirmed that he and Sue had specifically discussed the seacock's pipes and valves on board, so there was no doubt she was aware of their functions. Upon returning home, Sue called Star 10 Hash to make sure there hadn't been any unanswered calls that could discredit her alibi. At 7.04am, she called her mobile phone,
将鲍勃的尸体压沉并扔进海里。正是在这个过程中的某个时候，她弄伤了手腕并割伤了拇指。利用她对“四风号”内部运作的了解，苏随后切断了管道，打开了通海阀，并关闭了舱底泵和警报器，试图沉没游艇并销毁证据。一位曾在1月初在船上工作的机械师证实，他和苏专门讨论过船上的通海阀管道和阀门，所以毫无疑问她知道它们的功能。回到家后，苏拨打了“星10井号”，以确保没有任何未接来电可以反驳她的不在场证明。早上7点04分，她拨打了她的手机，
which she'd intentionally left on board the four winds. If the phone failed to ring, it would tell her that the yacht was submerged. Although this was all circumstantial, the pieces began to fit together. All that was missing was a motive. A little over two weeks before Bob Chappell went missing, Sue Neil Fraser spoke with the yacht broker who sold them the four winds and said that she and Bob had separated. When he expressed his sympathy, Sue said something along the lines of being, quote, tired of having to do everything. The two hired crew members who escorted Bob and Sue to Tasmania noticed there was no affection between the couple. At one point, Sue remarked
她有意将手机留在了“四风号”上。如果电话没响，就说明游艇已经沉没了。虽然这些都是间接证据，但各部分开始拼凑在一起。唯一缺少的是动机。在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪前两周多一点，苏·尼尔-弗雷泽曾与卖给他们“四风号”的游艇经纪人交谈，说她和鲍勃已经分居了。当对方表示同情时，苏说了一些类似“厌倦了不得不做所有事情”的话。两名护送鲍勃和苏前往塔斯马尼亚的受雇船员注意到这对夫妇之间没有任何亲昵表现。有一次，苏评论说
that her relationship with Bob had been strained for some time and was coming to an end. She was thinking about borrowing $100,000 from her mother to pay for Bob's share of their yacht. When the couple were reunited in Hobart, Sue stood back and ignored Bob when he tried to approach her. When he went missing, Sue told one of her yacht mechanics that she and Bob had broken up. Bob's children weren't aware that the couple had intentions of splitting, but his son Timothy had noticed some obvious tension between them in the weeks leading up to his father's disappearance. He attributed it to them wanting different things from the yacht. Sue hoped to go on long overseas voyages while Bob wanted to set sail on smaller trips.
她与鲍勃的关系已经紧张了一段时间，即将走到尽头。她当时正考虑向母亲借10万美元来支付鲍勃那份游艇的钱。当这对夫妇在霍巴特重聚时，苏站在一旁，无视了试图接近她的鲍勃。鲍勃失踪后，苏告诉她的一位游艇机械师，她和鲍勃已经分手了。鲍勃的孩子们并不知道这对夫妇有分手的打算，但他的儿子蒂莫西在父亲失踪前的几周里，注意到了他们之间明显的紧张关系。他将其归因于他们对游艇的需求不同。苏希望进行长期的海外航行，而鲍勃则想进行短途航行。
It was clear that purchasing the four winds had introduced some conflict into the couple's relationship, but this didn't explain why Sue would want to kill her partner of 20 years. Five years before he disappeared, Bob amended his will to ensure that Sue would be well taken care of in the event of his death. She was set to inherit his West Hobart home, car, personal possessions, and 50% of the residue of his $1.3 million estate. Sue hadn't been present when Bob made these changes, and his lawyer couldn't confirm whether Sue knew what she stood to inherit. Yet, Sue had spoken to one of Bob's daughters about the will previously, remarking that Bob had designated a fair amount to everyone.
很明显，购买“四风号”给这对夫妇的关系带来了冲突，但这并不能解释苏为什么要杀害与她相伴20年的伴侣。在鲍勃失踪五年前，他修改了遗嘱，以确保苏在他去世后能得到妥善照顾。她将继承他在西霍巴特的房子、汽车、个人物品以及他130万美元遗产中50%的剩余部分。鲍勃做出这些更改时苏并不在场，他的律师也无法确认苏是否知道她将继承什么。然而，苏之前曾与鲍勃的一个女儿谈论过遗嘱，称鲍勃为每个人都留了一笔可观的遗产。
Sue had since visited Bob's lawyer to discuss what needed to happen to release Bob's estate. If the couple were on the brink of separation as several witnesses had described, it stood to reason that Sue would lose what she was owed from Bob's will. In addition to the generous inheritance, Bob's death also meant Sue would acquire his half of the four winds without having to buy him out. Philip Trifford had helped work on Sue Neil Fraser's previous yacht during the 1990s. Philip claimed that Sue had once mentioned she was feuding with her mother. She was worried that her brother Patrick would therefore inherit all of her mother's money
此后，苏曾拜访过鲍勃的律师，讨论释放鲍勃遗产所需办理的手续。如果正如几位证人所描述的那样，这对夫妇处于分居边缘，那么苏很可能会失去她在鲍勃遗嘱中应得的份额。除了丰厚的遗产外，鲍勃的去世还意味着苏无需买断即可获得“四风号”的另一半所有权。菲利普·特里福特曾在20世纪90年代帮助苏·尼尔-弗雷泽修理过她之前的游艇。菲利普声称，苏曾提到她与母亲不和。她担心因此她的兄弟帕特里克会继承她母亲所有的钱。
when she passed away. According to Philip, Sue said she wanted to get rid of Patrick by throwing him overboard and had asked for Philip's assistance in doing so. Her plan was to weigh Patrick down with a toolbox and then sink the yacht by tampering with the bilge pump. Later, Sue told Philip about some problems she was having in her relationship with Bob Chapel. She claimed that Bob was unkind with money and had been exhibiting some troubling behaviour. After drinking one night, Bob apparently became convinced there was an intruder in their house and started running around with a knife. This worried Sue. She was concerned that Bob was dangerous and wanted him gone.
在她去世后。据菲利普说，苏说她想通过把帕特里克扔进海里来除掉他，并请求菲利普协助。她的计划是用工具箱压住帕特里克，然后通过破坏舱底泵来沉没游艇。后来，苏告诉菲利普她与鲍勃·查佩尔的关系出现了一些问题。她声称鲍勃在金钱上很刻薄，并表现出一些令人不安的行为。一天晚上喝醉后，鲍勃似乎确信家里有入侵者，开始拿着刀到处跑。这让苏很担心。她担心鲍勃很危险，想让他消失。
She suggested to Philip that they do to Bob what she had earlier proposed they do to her brother. Only this time, they would also wrap a Bob in chicken wire before throwing him overboard. Philip had been taken aback by Sue's plan and tried to alert Bob, but Sue denied his allegations. Consequently, it marked the end of their friendship. Although investigators had been suspicious of Sue from the get-go, they withheld this information from her. They wanted to rule out other possibilities. When no other suspects immediately came to light, they narrowed in on Sue. And with the circumstantial evidence mounting against her, it was time to act. Just over a month after Bob
她向菲利普建议，对鲍勃采取她之前提议对她兄弟采取的行动。只是这一次，他们还要在把鲍勃扔进海里之前用铁丝网把他裹起来。菲利普被苏的计划吓了一跳，并试图提醒鲍勃，但苏否认了他的指控。结果，他们的友谊走到了尽头。虽然调查人员从一开始就怀疑苏，但他们对她隐瞒了这些信息。他们想排除其他可能性。当没有其他嫌疑人立即浮出水面时，他们锁定了苏。随着针对她的间接证据越来越多，是时候采取行动了。在鲍勃失踪一个多月后，
vanished, covert listening devices were planted in Sue's home and on her phone. Investigators discovered that she had hired a lawyer who advised her not to speak to the police. Regardless, the next day, Sue voluntarily agreed to her first video interview. At this point, the police were still gathering information for their investigation and didn't caution Sue that she was considered a suspect. Therefore, she didn't ask to bring her lawyer. Therefore, she didn't ask to bring her lawyer. They asked Sue how things had been between her and Bob when she left him on the yacht. She said they'd been squabbling.
秘密监听设备被安装在苏的家中和她的手机上。调查人员发现她聘请了一位律师，律师建议她不要与警方交谈。尽管如此，第二天，苏还是自愿同意接受了第一次视频采访。此时，警方仍在收集调查信息，并没有提醒苏她已被视为嫌疑人。因此，她没有要求带上她的律师。因此，她没有要求带上她的律师。他们问苏，当她在游艇上离开鲍勃时，他们之间的情况如何。她说他们一直在争吵。
Bob was frustrated about the ongoing work that needed to be done to the boat. He'd given Sue a lecture about how awful it was to work full time while dedicating his spare time to the repairs. Sue repeated her story about visiting Bunnings after she got back to shore, adding that she had felt guilty at the time because Bob wouldn't be able to reach her if he called their landline. This was the big chance for investigators to catch Sue in her own lie. They made the big reveal. Sue hadn't been caught on any CCTV footage and the store's opening hours that day didn't align with her timeline.
鲍勃对船上需要进行的持续工作感到沮丧。他曾教训苏，说一边全职工作，一边把业余时间投入到维修中是多么糟糕。苏重复了她回到岸上后去邦宁斯（Bunnings）的说法，并补充说她当时感到内疚，因为如果鲍勃拨打他们的座机，他将无法联系到她。这是调查人员抓住苏谎言的绝佳机会。他们揭开了真相。苏并没有出现在任何闭路电视录像中，而且该店当天的营业时间与她的时间表不符。
Sue replied that she was pretty sure she had been at Bunnings on the afternoon in question. She maintained that she didn't leave the house again after returning home. When asked why she didn't report the alleged break-ins on the four wins, Sue said Bob was reluctant to do so because he didn't want to give their boat a bad reputation. She claimed to have called the drug squad at the time to inquire about having sniffer dogs search the vessel, but Bob had requested she didn't pursue the matter. After the interview, detectives called every drug investigation unit in Tasmania. No one recalled receiving an inquiry of this nature.
苏回答说，她很确定自己在那个下午去了邦宁斯。她坚持说，回到家后她就再也没有离开过房子。当被问及为什么没有报告“四风号”上所谓的入室盗窃案时，苏说鲍勃不愿这样做，因为他不想给他们的船带来坏名声。她声称当时曾致电缉毒组询问是否可以用嗅探犬搜查船只，但鲍勃要求她不要追究此事。采访结束后，侦探们致电了塔斯马尼亚的所有缉毒部门。没有人记得收到过此类询问。
Over a month after Bob vanished, Sue sat down with radio journalist Felicity Ogilvy having agreed to be interviewed about the case. As they chatted prior to the interview officially starting, Sue made a revelation. She spoke about the phone call she'd received from Richard on the night of January 26 regarding Bob's estranged daughter, Lisa. As Lisa had expressed concerns for Bob and his yacht, Sue wanted to check on them both to see if all was okay. Sue then admitted to Felicity that she didn't stay home the entire night of January 26. She drove to Maryville Esplanade. There were a few homeless people gathered around a fire on the
在鲍勃失踪一个多月后，苏与广播记者费利西蒂·奥格尔维坐下来，同意就此案接受采访。在采访正式开始前的闲聊中，苏透露了一个信息。她谈到了1月26日晚上她接到理查德关于鲍勃疏远的女儿丽莎的电话。由于丽莎对鲍勃和他的游艇表示担忧，苏想去看看他们两人是否一切安好。苏随后向费利西蒂承认，1月26日晚上她并没有整晚待在家里。她开车去了玛丽维尔滨海大道。有几个无家可归的人在海滩上的火堆旁聚集，
beach, but there didn't appear to be anything suspicious going on on the four wins out at sea. Having put her mind at ease, Sue returned home. Assuming this was a detailed police were already aware of, Felicity Ogilvy mentioned it in passing during a subsequent interview with detectives. It was the first they'd heard of it. Given that Sue had staunchly maintained to them that she'd never left their house on the night of January 26, her comments placing her at the scene were huge. Investigators would soon discover that Felicity wasn't the only person Sue had made this admission to. In a phone call with Bob's sister, Anne, over two months after he disappeared,
但海上的“四风号”似乎并没有什么可疑之处。在放下心来后，苏回到了家。费利西蒂·奥格尔维以为这是警方已经掌握的细节，便在随后的侦探采访中顺口提到了这一点。这是他们第一次听说这件事。鉴于苏一直坚定地向他们坚称1月26日晚上她从未离开过家，她将自己置于现场的言论非常重要。调查人员很快就会发现，费利西蒂并不是苏唯一向其做出此项承认的人。在鲍勃失踪两个多月后，与鲍勃的妹妹安妮的通话中，
Sue once again spoke of having driven down to Maryville Esplanade. In this account, she added that she had left her car there so she could walk home for exercise. By mid-April, almost three months had passed with no sign of Bob Chapel. Police divers once again entered the waters of Sandy Bay. Using advanced sonar equipment, they searched an area measuring one nautical mile long and half a nautical mile wide from where the four winds had been moored. They found various items, including old dinghies, moorings, discarded wheelie bins, and concrete blocks, but nothing relevant to the chapel case. Investigators remained certain that Bob's body had been dumped in the bay and was
苏再次提到她开车去了玛丽维尔滨海大道。在这次叙述中，她补充说她把车留在了那里，这样她就可以步行回家锻炼。到4月中旬，近三个月过去了，鲍勃·查佩尔仍杳无音信。警方潜水员再次进入桑迪湾的水域。利用先进的声纳设备，他们搜索了距离“四风号”停泊处一海里长、半海里宽的区域。他们发现了各种物品，包括旧小艇、系泊设备、废弃的轮式垃圾桶和混凝土块，但没有发现与查佩尔案相关的任何东西。调查人员仍然确信鲍勃的尸体被倾倒在海湾中，并且
hidden in the murky depths or had since drifted outside of their search zone. On May 5, 2009, Sue Neil Fraser once again participated in a video interview with police. This time, she was cautioned that she was officially being treated as a suspect in Bob's disappearance. Sue admitted she must have been mistaken when she initially said she'd been at Bunnings on the afternoon of January 26. She explained she must have gotten her days mixed up due to being in a state of shock after Bob went missing. Sue and Bob visited Bunnings frequently to buy items for the boat, and she simply had trouble differentiating one day from the next. When told about the witness reports that placed a dinghy at the four winds between four and five
隐藏在浑浊的深处，或者此后漂流到了他们的搜索区域之外。2009年5月5日，苏·尼尔-弗雷泽再次参加了警方的视频采访。这一次，她被警告说她已被正式列为鲍勃失踪案的嫌疑人。苏承认，她最初说1月26日下午她在邦宁斯时一定是记错了。她解释说，由于鲍勃失踪后她处于震惊状态，她一定把日子搞混了。苏和鲍勃经常去邦宁斯购买船用物品，她只是很难区分哪天是哪天。当被告知有证人报告称在下午四点到五点之间看到一艘小艇停在“四风号”旁时，
p.m., Sue completely changed her story. She claimed she must have stayed aboard the yacht later than she initially thought. After returning to shore and tying the dinghy up at the Royal Yacht Club, she left her car at either Maryville Esplanade or around the corner on Margaret Street. She couldn't be sure exactly. She then walked the 2.7km route home, which took about 40 minutes. Later that night, after receiving the call from Richard about Lisa, she became concerned. She didn't want to call Bob in case she woke him. Instead, Sue decided to walk down to collect her car in case Bob later called her from the yacht wanting to be picked up. When Sue reached her car, she realized she'd brought the wrong set of keys. She walked home, got the right set, and walked back.
苏完全改变了她的说法。她声称她一定是在游艇上待的时间比她最初认为的要晚。回到岸上并将小艇系在皇家游艇俱乐部后，她把车停在玛丽维尔滨海大道或玛格丽特街的拐角处。她无法确定具体位置。然后她步行了2.7公里的路程回家，大约花了40分钟。那天晚上晚些时候，在接到理查德关于丽莎的电话后，她开始担心。她不想给鲍勃打电话，以免吵醒他。相反，苏决定步行去取车，以防鲍勃后来从游艇上打电话给她，要求去接他。当苏到达车旁时，她意识到自己带错了钥匙。她走回家，拿了正确的钥匙，又走了回来。
Once she returned to her vehicle, she drove along the rowing sheds on Maryville Esplanade, parked the car, and walked onto the beach. It was pitch black and too dark to see the four winds in the distance, but she noticed there were some homeless people sitting around a fire. This made her feel better, so she drove home. Sue said she'd initially lied about going to the Esplanade because she didn't want to upset Bob's other children if they found out about the phone call concerning their sister's welfare. The police told Sue that the red yachting jacket she denied owning had tested positive for her DNA. She conceded that the jacket belonged to her. It was a spare kept on board for
回到车上后，她沿着玛丽维尔滨海大道的划船棚开车，停好车，走到了海滩上。当时漆黑一片，太黑了，看不清远处的“四风号”，但她注意到有一些无家可归的人坐在火堆旁。这让她感觉好了一些，于是她开车回家了。苏说，她最初撒谎说去了滨海大道，是因为她不想让鲍勃的其他孩子在发现关于他们姐妹福利的电话后感到不安。警方告诉苏，她否认拥有的红色游艇夹克检测出了她的DNA。她承认这件夹克是她的。这是船上为客人准备的备用夹克。
guests. However, she had no idea how it ended up on the street. For investigators, Sue was only digging herself into a deeper hole. They believed she had a conveniently selective memory wherein she changed her story whenever she was presented with evidence that disproved her previous statements. She had denied the jacket was hers until DNA testing proved otherwise. She'd stuck with her story about being at Bunnings until security footage showed she was never there. She was adamant she had never left her house on the night of January 26th, until a car matching the description of the one she drove was captured on CCTV,
然而，她不知道它是怎么出现在街上的。对调查人员来说，苏只是在自掘坟墓。他们认为她有一种方便的选择性记忆，每当有证据反驳她之前的陈述时，她就会改变说法。她一直否认夹克是她的，直到DNA检测证明事实并非如此。她一直坚持自己在邦宁斯的说法，直到监控录像显示她从未去过那里。她坚称1月26日晚上她从未离开过家，直到一辆与她驾驶的车辆描述相符的汽车被闭路电视拍到，
and after she'd slipped up by telling the radio journalist that she'd driven to the beach. In early August 2009, Sue wrote an official letter to the Commissioner of Police and the Officer in Charge of Internal Affairs to complain about the way she was being treated. Concerned that the police were targeting her and not considering other possibilities, she requested that an independent review be conducted into Bob's disappearance. Her request was denied. Instead, investigators were confident they had enough circumstantial evidence to warrant an arrest. On August 20, Sunil Fraser was charged with the murder of Bob Chapel.
而且在她向广播记者说漏嘴，承认自己开车去了海滩之后。2009年8月初，苏写了一封正式信函给警察局长和内务部负责人，投诉她所受到的对待。由于担心警方针对她而不考虑其他可能性，她要求对鲍勃的失踪进行独立审查。她的请求被拒绝了。相反，调查人员确信他们有足够的间接证据来实施逮捕。2009年8月20日，苏·尼尔-弗雷泽被控谋杀鲍勃·查佩尔。
Seven months later in March 2010, a 15-year-old homeless girl named Megan Vass was arrested in Tasmania. As per standard procedure, her DNA was run through the police database. It returned a match that nobody was expecting. Megan's DNA had been detected at another unrelated crime scene. On board the four wins. A forensic examination of the yacht had uncovered a dinner plate-sized DNA profile thought to have come from such bodily fluid as vomit, urine, or saliva. Testing confirmed it didn't belong to Sunil Fraser and its source had remained unknown, until now. Megan Vass had no known connection to Bob Chapel, Sunil Fraser, or the four wins, so there was no reasonable explanation for the presence of her DNA on the yacht.
七个月后的2010年3月，一名名叫梅根·瓦斯的15岁无家可归女孩在塔斯马尼亚被捕。按照标准程序，她的DNA被输入了警方数据库。结果返回了一个没人预料到的匹配结果。梅根的DNA在另一个无关的犯罪现场被检测到。在“四风号”上。对游艇的法医检查发现了一个餐盘大小的DNA图谱，被认为来自呕吐物、尿液或唾液等体液。检测证实它不属于苏·尼尔-弗雷泽，其来源一直未知，直到现在。梅根·瓦斯与鲍勃·查佩尔、苏·尼尔-弗雷泽或“四风号”没有任何已知的联系，因此她的DNA出现在游艇上没有合理的解释。
Her fingerprints were compared to those found on board, but none were a match. Police searched for any other evidence that placed the teen on the four wins at any time, but found nothing. Police set up an interview with Megan Vass so they could question her about her whereabouts on January 26, the previous year. She never showed up. They scheduled a second interview, but she didn't attend that one either. As she was a minor with no adult guardian, they couldn't force her to speak. Megan was free to go about her life while Sunil Fraser's legal team scrambled to prove her innocence. They believed that police had tunnel vision on Sue, which led them to carry out an inadequate investigation.
她的指纹与船上发现的指纹进行了比对，但没有匹配。警方搜寻了任何其他能证明这名少女在任何时候登上过“四风号”的证据，但一无所获。警方安排了与梅根·瓦斯的采访，以便询问她前一年1月26日的行踪。她从未露面。他们安排了第二次采访，但她也没有参加。由于她是未成年人，没有成年监护人，他们无法强迫她开口。梅根可以自由地继续她的生活，而苏·尼尔-弗雷泽的法律团队则竭尽全力证明她的清白。他们认为警方对苏有“隧道视野”，导致他们进行了不充分的调查。
The dinghy sided roped up to the four wins on the afternoon Bob vanished was described as charcoal gray. Bob and Sue's Quicksilver Dinghy was blue and white. One witness saw a lone, seemingly female figure traveling on a dinghy towards Bob's yacht at 11.30pm. Police were quick to conclude that this person was Sue, yet it could have been Megan Vass or it might not have been a woman at all. A man named Grant had also been moored in the same area as the four wins on the night of January 26, 2009. He was described as slim with delicate features and wavy shoulder length hair. It was possible that the witness had seen Grant and confused his silhouette for that of a female. Then there was the assertion that Sue had lifted Bob's body using a winch before placing it in
鲍勃失踪那天下午系在“四风号”旁的小艇被描述为炭灰色。鲍勃和苏的“快银”小艇是蓝白色的。一名证人看到一个孤独的、看似女性的身影在晚上11点30分乘坐小艇前往鲍勃的游艇。警方很快断定此人就是苏，但它可能是梅根·瓦斯，或者根本就不是女性。一个名叫格兰特的人在2009年1月26日晚上也停泊在与“四风号”相同的区域。他被描述为身材苗条，五官精致，留着波浪状的齐肩长发。证人可能看到了格兰特，并把他的轮廓误认为是女性。此外，还有一种说法是苏使用绞盘吊起了鲍勃的尸体，然后将其放入
the dinghy and dumping it at sea. Several witnesses confirmed Sue couldn't use the winch without assistance due to a back injury. The Quicksilver Dinghy was tested with luminol, a chemical used to detect blood, and several areas had reacted positively. However, as luminol cannot be 100% relied on, another screening agent and microscopic examination were also used. This time, they returned negative results. There was no forensic evidence to conclusively prove there was or had been any blood in the dinghy at all. No other witnesses who had contact with Sue the morning after Bob's disappearance recalled seeing a bandage on her wrist or bandaid on her thumb. The interviewing officer who noticed
小艇并倾倒在海里。几位证人证实，由于背部受伤，苏在没有帮助的情况下无法使用绞盘。警方用鲁米诺（一种用于检测血液的化学物质）对“快银”小艇进行了测试，几个区域反应呈阳性。然而，由于鲁米诺不能100%依赖，他们还使用了另一种筛选剂和显微镜检查。这一次，结果呈阴性。没有任何法医证据可以确凿地证明小艇上有或曾经有过任何血液。在鲍勃失踪后的第二天早上与苏接触的其他证人都不记得看到她手腕上有绷带或拇指上有创可贴。注意到
the injury said he told the detective in charge of the investigation about what he saw. But he didn't take any photographs or notes about the injury at the time, nor did he request it to be examined. An inverted latex glove uncovered on the four wins led investigators to assume that Sue had endeavored to clean the yacht prior to sabotaging it. The glove contained fingerprints, but they matched Bob's son, Timothy, who said he'd recently been on the yacht as a guest. Although financial gain was a common motive for murder, Sue was not desperate for money. While she no longer worked full-time, she owned three investment properties, and Bob had been providing her an allowance of $500 a fortnight for living expenses. If she hoped to inherit
伤口的采访警官说，他告诉了负责调查的侦探他所看到的情况。但他当时没有拍摄任何照片或做笔记，也没有要求对伤口进行检查。在“四风号”上发现的一只翻过来的乳胶手套让调查人员推测，苏在破坏游艇之前曾试图清理它。手套上有指纹，但与鲍勃的儿子蒂莫西的指纹相符，他说他最近曾作为客人登上过游艇。虽然经济利益是谋杀的常见动机，但苏并不缺钱。虽然她不再全职工作，但她拥有三处投资性房产，而且鲍勃一直给她提供每两周500美元的生活费。如果她希望继承
Bob's half of the four wins, it didn't make sense that she would then attempt to sink the vessel in the process. Although her story changed, Sue willingly spoke with police and aided in their investigations. She even pointed out the things that were missing or out of place on the yacht. Were these the actions of someone who had something to hide? Sue's trial commenced in Tasmania's Supreme Court in September 2010. With no body, no weapon, no witnesses, and nothing to conclusively prove that Bob Chapel was deceased, the case against her was built entirely on circumstantial evidence. The prosecution called 60 witnesses to the stand. Among them was Peter, one of the crew
鲍勃那一半的“四风号”，那么她在过程中试图沉没这艘船就说不通了。虽然她的说法变了，但苏愿意与警方交谈并协助他们的调查。她甚至指出了游艇上丢失或放错位置的东西。这些是一个有隐情的人的行为吗？苏的审判于2010年9月在塔斯马尼亚最高法院开始。由于没有尸体、没有凶器、没有证人，也没有任何确凿证据证明鲍勃·查佩尔已经死亡，针对她的案件完全建立在间接证据之上。检方传唤了60名证人出庭。其中包括彼得，他是帮助将“四风号”从昆士兰航行到塔斯马尼亚的船员之一。
members who helped sail the four wins from Queensland to Tasmania. He was one of several people who claimed that Sue told him her relationship with Bob was over. In earlier police interviews, Sue claimed that Peter drank heavily during the voyage, implying that he might have gotten things mixed up. On the stand, Peter took offense to this. He stated that the most he ever drank was one or two glasses of wine during dinner, and he was nowhere near intoxicated at any time on the journey. Under cross-examination, Sue's lawyer put it to Peter that someone with intimate knowledge of the four wins would know there were easier ways to sink it than by cutting the 75mm pipe near the toilet. Peter agreed. It would be quicker to sink the boat by opening the main
他是声称苏告诉他她与鲍勃的关系已经结束的几个人之一。在早期的警方采访中，苏声称彼得在航行期间酗酒，暗示他可能把事情搞混了。在证人席上，彼得对此感到冒犯。他表示，他喝得最多的时候也就是晚餐时喝一两杯葡萄酒，在旅途中的任何时候他都远未达到醉酒状态。在交叉询问中，苏的律师向彼得提出，一个对“四风号”有深入了解的人会知道，比起切断厕所附近的75毫米管道，有更容易的方法来沉没它。彼得表示同意。通过打开主
engine inlet valve. However, Peter also noted that the slower method might be the best option if the person responsible wanted to get off the yacht and out of sight before anyone noticed it was sinking. Sue's former friend Philip Triffett took the stand to repeat his story about Sue saying she wanted to kill both her brother and Bob and throw them overboard. This had allegedly happened in the 90s. When the defence asked Philip why he didn't report either of these conversations to police at the time, he claimed he didn't think the threats would ever eventuate. The defence wasn't buying it. They argued that if Philip's claims were true, it was absurd to think that Sue would have carried out the plan a decade after first mentioning it. As the defence pointed out,
发动机进水阀沉没船只的速度会更快。然而，彼得也指出，如果责任人想在任何人注意到船只正在下沉之前离开游艇并消失，那么较慢的方法可能是最佳选择。苏的前朋友菲利普·特里菲特出庭重复了他的故事，称苏说她想杀死她的兄弟和鲍勃，并把他们扔进海里。这据称发生在90年代。当辩方问菲利普为什么当时没有向警方报告这些谈话时，他声称他认为这些威胁永远不会实现。辩方不相信。他们辩称，如果菲利普的说法是真的，那么认为苏会在第一次提到这些计划十年后才实施，这是荒谬的。正如辩方指出的那样，
Philip had passed convictions for physical assault, traffic infringement and unlawful possession of a firearm. At the time Bob Chappell went missing, Philip was on bail and had asked police whether providing information about Bob and Sue's history would help with his current charges. The defence urged the jury to reject these claims on the basis that Philip Triffett was a dishonest man who was hoping to gain a personal advantage from giving false evidence. Instead, they criticised police for not seriously investigating Sue's concerns that someone might have used the four wins to smuggle drugs. James, a marine mechanic who had conducted repairs on the yacht while it was birthed in Queensland, gave evidence that while working on the yacht, he raised concerns of a
菲利普有身体伤害、交通违规和非法持有枪支的定罪记录。在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪时，菲利普正在保释中，并询问警方提供关于鲍勃和苏历史的信息是否会有助于他当前的指控。辩方敦促陪审团拒绝这些说法，理由是菲利普·特里菲特是一个不诚实的人，希望通过提供虚假证据来获得个人利益。相反，他们批评警方没有认真调查苏关于可能有人利用“四风号”走私毒品的担忧。詹姆斯，一名在游艇停泊在昆士兰期间进行维修的船舶机械师，提供了证据，称在游艇上工作时，他提出了关于
break-in. James had noticed that on two or three occasions, the boom cover, which is a tarpaulin that covers the cockpit to protect it from the elements, was tied down differently to the way he had left it. Several items on board had also been moved around. As the four wins was kept on a locked pier overnight, James suspected someone was accessing the yacht from the sea. Rattled, he had phoned Sue to voice his concerns, including that he felt like someone was watching him. However, during cross-examination, James revealed he later found out that an electrician had been working on the boat after hours, which accounted for this suspicious activity. He had informed Sue of this. This implied she knew the boat hadn't been broken into,
入室盗窃的担忧。詹姆斯注意到，有两三次，吊杆罩（一种覆盖驾驶舱以保护其免受自然因素影响的防水布）的系法与他离开时不同。船上的几件物品也被移动过。由于“四风号”晚上停在有锁的码头上，詹姆斯怀疑有人从海上进入游艇。感到不安的他打电话给苏表达了他的担忧，包括他觉得有人在监视他。然而，在交叉询问中，詹姆斯透露他后来发现一名电工在下班后在船上工作，这解释了这种可疑活动。他已将此事告知苏。这意味着她知道船并没有被闯入，
yet had still used these incidents to bolster her drug-smuggling theory. While there were compelling arguments both for and against Sue's innocence, one giant question loomed. How had Megan Vass's DNA got on board the four wins? The case's DNA profiler confirmed that the dinner plate-sized DNA profile belonged to Megan Vass at a probability of 1 in 100 million. Although rare, he said it was entirely possible that Megan's DNA ended up on the four wins through secondary transfer, without her ever having been on board. Speculatively speaking, it was possible that the DNA had been walked onto the yacht from someone's shoe, although he didn't recall an instance in his career where such an
却仍然利用这些事件来支持她的毒品走私理论。虽然支持和反对苏清白的论点都很引人注目，但一个巨大的问题挥之不去。梅根·瓦斯的DNA是如何出现在“四风号”上的？该案的DNA分析师证实，餐盘大小的DNA图谱属于梅根·瓦斯，概率为1亿分之一。虽然罕见，但他表示，梅根的DNA完全有可能通过二次转移出现在“四风号”上，而她本人从未上过船。从推测的角度来看，DNA有可能通过某人的鞋子被带到游艇上，尽管他职业生涯中不记得发生过这样的
incident had occurred. There had actually been some other items found on board that also appeared to have been covered in vomit, a small blue face washer and two wet rags. These had been bagged as evidence and appeared on the forensic report tended in court, but they were never forensically tested, nor mentioned during the trial. By this point, Megan Vass had been tracked down and was called to testify. She told the jury that in late January of 2009, she was living in a complex in Lana Valley, a suburb six and a half kilometers north of Sandy Bay. She had never been on board the four wins and couldn't recall whether she was anywhere near Sandy Bay at the time of Bob Chapel's disappearance, explaining why she refused to be interviewed by the police when her DNA was
事件。船上实际上还发现了一些其他物品，似乎也沾满了呕吐物，包括一块蓝色小面巾和两块湿抹布。这些作为证据被装袋，并出现在法庭提交的法医报告中，但它们从未经过法医鉴定，在审判期间也没有被提及。此时，梅根·瓦斯已被找到并被传唤作证。她告诉陪审团，2009年1月底，她住在桑迪湾以北6.5公里的郊区拉纳谷的一个综合大楼里。她从未登上过“四风号”，也不记得在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪时她是否在桑迪湾附近，这解释了为什么当她的DNA被
first linked to the case. Megan said she was intimidated by law enforcement and by the magnitude of the situation. After giving her testimony, Megan was free to leave. However, something she said raised a red flag. Before the jury had been summoned in, Megan told the court that she'd been living in a women's refuge in Montrose at the time of Bob Chapel's disappearance, not Lana Valley, like she told the jury. The two suburbs were roughly six kilometers apart and not easily confused. Furthermore, one of the detectives who had looked into Megan after her DNA was identified told a completely different story. During his inquiries, he discovered that in late January 2009, Megan was living at a woman's shelter called Mara House in the inner northern
首次与此案联系起来时，她拒绝接受警方采访。梅根说她被执法部门和局势的严重性吓到了。作证后，梅根可以自由离开。然而，她说的一件事引起了警觉。在陪审团被传唤之前，梅根告诉法庭，她在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪时住在蒙特罗斯的一家妇女收容所，而不是像她告诉陪审团的那样住在拉纳谷。这两个郊区相距约6公里，不容易混淆。此外，在她的DNA被识别后调查梅根的侦探之一讲述了一个完全不同的故事。在调查过程中，他发现2009年1月底，梅根住在位于内北部的一个名为玛拉之家的妇女收容所。
suburb of Newtown. Shelter policy required anyone who intended to spend the night off grounds tell the staff where they were going. On the night of January 26, staff recalled that Megan spent the night away and had given them the address of a unit in Mount Nelson, a suburb just above Sandy Bay. The detective looked into it and discovered it was a fake address. This was the first time this information had come to light, but by this point, Megan Vass had already been dismissed from court. The judge decided not to recall her and simply instructed the jury to ignore this information from the detective, as it was only hearsay. As the trial progressed, Sunil Fraser was called to the stand as the sole witness for the
郊区纽敦。收容所政策要求任何打算在外面过夜的人告知工作人员他们的去向。1月26日晚上，工作人员回忆说梅根在外过夜，并给了他们一个位于芒特纳尔逊的单元房地址，这是一个就在桑迪湾上方的郊区。侦探调查后发现这是一个假地址。这是该信息首次曝光，但此时梅根·瓦斯已经被法庭驳回。法官决定不传唤她，只是指示陪审团忽略侦探提供的这些信息，因为这只是传闻。随着审判的进行，苏·尼尔-弗雷泽作为唯一的证人被传唤到证人席上。
defense. For four days, she was subject to intense questioning. Sue denied ever saying that her relationship with Bob was over. On the contrary, they had planned to get married on their upcoming 20th anniversary. She strongly denied ever telling her former friend, Philip Triffett, that she wanted her brother and Bob dead. She claimed the real reason her friendship with Philip deteriorated was because he was stockpiling weapons and it made her and Bob very uncomfortable. Additionally, Philip's partner at the time had told them that Philip had burned her house down for insurance money and that he had once killed a man. Sue stuck by the story that she sometimes strapped her wrist due to an old boating injury that often flared up. As for the band-aid,
辩方。四天来，她受到了激烈的盘问。苏否认曾说过她与鲍勃的关系已经结束。相反，他们计划在即将到来的20周年纪念日结婚。她强烈否认曾告诉她的前朋友菲利普·特里菲特她想让她的兄弟和鲍勃死。她声称她与菲利普的友谊恶化的真正原因是他在囤积武器，这让她和鲍勃感到非常不舒服。此外，菲利普当时的伴侣告诉他们，菲利普为了保险金烧毁了她的房子，而且他曾经杀过一个人。苏坚持说，她有时会绑住手腕，因为旧的划船伤经常复发。至于创可贴，
the interviewing officer recalled seeing on her left thumb the morning of Bob's disappearance. Sue claimed to have no recollection of cutting herself. She said she must have been scratched by her cat. She admitted it was quote, very silly that she'd kept word of her trip to Sandy Bay on the night of January 26th a secret. She said she hadn't been thinking clearly at the time. The prosecution accused Sue of planting red herrings to direct the investigation away from herself. Sue disputed this, explaining that one of the reasons she withheld information from police was that she began suffering acute mental blackouts a few days after Bob's disappearance. She stated, it was as if everything was receding and then I would basically not know where I was,
采访警官回忆说，在鲍勃失踪那天早上看到她左拇指上有创可贴。苏声称不记得自己割伤了自己。她说她一定是被猫抓伤了。她承认，她对1月26日晚上去桑迪湾的行程保密是“非常愚蠢的”。她说她当时没有清醒地思考。检方指控苏设置红鲱鱼（干扰项）以将调查引向远离她自己的方向。苏对此提出异议，解释说她向警方隐瞒信息的原因之一是她在鲍勃失踪几天后开始出现严重的精神空白。她陈述道：“就好像一切都在后退，然后我基本上不知道我在哪里，
just for a few seconds or a minute. Sue also claimed it was stress that had caused her to give incorrect recollections of her trip to Bunning's warehouse, hindered further by the fact that her days blended into one because she typically followed the same routine every day. The prosecution labelled these as false memories and suggested that Sue told so many lies she was unable to keep track of them all. The prosecution also accused Sue of exaggerating stories about the four wins being broken into to lead police towards that line of investigation. Her 2009 diary in which she had made note of a break-in that occurred on January 10 was presented to the court. This entry had been written using different coloured ink to other
只是几秒钟或一分钟。”苏还声称是压力导致她对邦宁斯仓库的行程给出了不正确的记忆，而且由于她通常每天遵循相同的日常工作，日子混在一起，这进一步阻碍了她的记忆。检方将这些标记为虚假记忆，并暗示苏撒了太多的谎，以至于她无法跟踪所有谎言。检方还指控苏夸大了关于“四风号”被闯入的故事，以引导警方进行该方向的调查。她2009年的日记中记录了1月10日发生的一起入室盗窃案，被提交给法庭。该条目使用了与其他条目不同的彩色墨水。
entries from the same day. The prosecution alleged this was because Sue had made the entry later on to give her story about the break-ins more credence. Sue denied this allegation, pointing out that most of her diary entries were written in different coloured ink. During her time on the stand, Sue often gave vague, non-committed responses. The judge cautioned her against this, but Sue ignored the caution and continued giving passive answers. Some perceived this as being uncertain and deceitful. When the prosecution blatantly accused Sue of killing Bob and dumping his body at sea for financial gain, Sue responded, There is not a grain of truth in any of this.
同一天的条目。检方声称这是因为苏后来才写下该条目，以使她关于入室盗窃的故事更具可信度。苏否认了这一指控，指出她的大多数日记条目都是用不同颜色的墨水写的。在证人席上，苏经常给出模糊、不承诺的回应。法官警告她不要这样做，但苏无视了警告，继续给出被动的回答。一些人认为这是不确定和欺骗性的。当检方公然指控苏为了经济利益杀害鲍勃并将他的尸体倾倒在海里时，苏回应道：“这一切中没有半点真实之处。”
After three weeks, Sue Norfraz's trial began wrapping up. Her lawyer reminded the jury that the prosecution's case was entirely circumstantial and Tasmanian law dictated that an individual couldn't be convicted of a crime when the evidence lies purely on suspicion. He said the prosecution's case ignored the evidence that clearly proved Sue was innocent, telling the jury, You hold Ms Norfraz's future in your hands today and you have a solemn duty to discharge in accordance with the oath that you took at the beginning of these proceedings to decide the case according to the evidence. That oath says nothing about suspicion.
三周后，苏·尼尔-弗雷泽的审判开始结束。她的律师提醒陪审团，检方的案件完全是间接的，塔斯马尼亚法律规定，当证据纯粹基于怀疑时，个人不能被判有罪。他说检方的案件忽略了清楚证明苏无罪的证据，告诉陪审团：“你们今天掌握着苏·尼尔-弗雷泽的未来，你们有庄严的职责，要按照你们在这些诉讼开始时所宣誓的那样，根据证据来决定案件。那个誓言中没有提到怀疑。”
The judge reiterated to the jury that telling a lie mustn't be treated as evidence suggesting guilt. He clarified, You may find Ms Norfraz guilty of murder if you're satisfied beyond reasonable doubt of all the following things. A. She killed Mr Chappell. B. The physical acts or acts by which she killed Mr Chappell were voluntary and intentional. C. At the time of the killing she intended to cause Mr Chappell's death. D. Her physical acts or acts were not justified under the provisions of the criminal code. D. The jury deliberated for 18 hours. For the murder of Bob Chappell they found Sue Norfraz guilty beyond reasonable doubt.
法官向陪审团重申，撒谎不能被视为暗示有罪的证据。他澄清说：“如果你们对以下所有事项感到排除合理怀疑，你们可以判定苏·尼尔-弗雷泽谋杀罪成立。A. 她杀害了查佩尔先生。B. 她杀害查佩尔先生的身体行为是自愿和故意的。C. 在杀人时，她意图导致查佩尔先生死亡。D. 她的身体行为在刑法规定下是不正当的。”陪审团审议了18个小时。对于谋杀鲍勃·查佩尔，他们判定苏·尼尔-弗雷泽排除合理怀疑有罪。
Sue was noticeably shocked by the outcome. She had been so convinced that the jury would find her innocent that she'd barely considered the alternative. Sentencing took place 12 days later. Bob's family chose not to provide victim impact statements in order to preserve their privacy. The judge stated he was satisfied beyond reasonable doubt that Sue had murdered Bob on board the four wins and used the dinghy to dump his body at sea for the purpose of her own financial gain. Quote, She seems to me to be clever, very cool headed and well able to control her emotions. This was not a killing that occurred because of a loss of self-control. It was not a crime of passion. It was an intentional and purposeful killing.
苏对结果感到明显震惊。她一直确信陪审团会判定她无罪，以至于她几乎没有考虑过其他选择。12天后进行了量刑。鲍勃的家人选择不提供受害者影响陈述，以保护他们的隐私。法官表示，他排除合理怀疑地确信苏在“四风号”上谋杀了鲍勃，并使用小艇将他的尸体倾倒在海里，目的是为了她自己的经济利益。“她在我看来很聪明，非常冷静，并且能够很好地控制自己的情绪。这不是因为失去自控力而发生的杀戮。这不是激情犯罪。这是一次蓄意和有目的的杀戮。”
Acknowledging that Sue had no prior convictions, the judge stated that her refusal to plead guilty or assist with locating Bob's body, coupled with her lack of remorse, warranted a heavier sentence than most murders. He therefore sentenced Sue Norfraz to 26 years with a non-parole period of 18 years, backdated to the date of her arrest. Sue appealed against her conviction straight away and in August 2011, her case was heard in the court of criminal appeal. The appeal was quashed immediately, but the appellate judges agreed that given her age and previously good character, her sentencing was excessive. Sue's sentence was reduced to 23 years with a non-parole period of 13 years, meaning she would be eligible for parole in 2022.
承认苏没有前科，法官表示，她拒绝认罪或协助寻找鲍勃的尸体，加上她缺乏悔意，导致了比大多数谋杀案更重的刑罚。因此，他判处苏·尼尔-弗雷泽26年监禁，不得假释期为18年，从她被捕之日起计算。苏立即对她的定罪提出上诉，2011年8月，她的案件在刑事上诉法院审理。上诉立即被驳回，但上诉法官同意，鉴于她的年龄和以前的良好品行，她的量刑过重。苏的刑期减为23年，不得假释期为13年，这意味着她将在2022年有资格获得假释。
Sue wasn't satisfied with this outcome. Six months later, she applied for special leave to appeal to the High Court of Australia on the grounds that the case against her was purely circumstantial. She argued that the DNA evidence belonging to Megan Vass found on board the four wins should be given further consideration. Her application was rejected that same day. Writing to a friend about her experiences, Sue said, It has been a pretty horrific few years for us. No one in our family had ever been involved in the criminal justice system, and we were therefore naive when it came to interacting with police. We had faith that if mistakes were made, there were checks and balances to address them.
苏对这个结果并不满意。六个月后，她以案件纯属间接证据为由，向澳大利亚高等法院申请特别上诉许可。她辩称，在“四风号”上发现的属于梅根·瓦斯的DNA证据应得到进一步考虑。她的申请在当天被拒绝。在写给朋友的一封信中，苏说：“这对我们来说是相当可怕的几年。我们家族中没有人参与过刑事司法系统，因此我们在与警方互动时很天真。我们相信，如果犯了错误，会有制衡机制来解决它们。”
Now, in hindsight, our worldview has changed, and of necessity, we find ourselves tumbling about in the eye of a turbulent fight for justice. As more time goes by since Bob disappeared, the more clearly I see what has happened, and just how outrageous the claims made by police and prosecution actually were. For Sue's appeal lawyer, Barbara Retter, one particular detail continued to play on her mind. In the weeks following Bob's disappearance, a man named Stephen Gleason had gone to the Hobart police station, wanting to report his sightings on the night of January 26, 2009. Gleason had been living in his car in Sandy Bay at the time, and knew Bob and Sue,
现在，回想起来，我们的世界观已经改变了，出于必要，我们发现自己陷入了一场动荡的正义斗争中。随着鲍勃失踪的时间越来越长，我越来越清楚地看到了发生了什么，以及警方和检方提出的主张实际上是多么离谱。对于苏的上诉律师芭芭拉·雷特来说，一个特定的细节继续在她的脑海中盘旋。在鲍勃失踪后的几周里，一个名叫斯蒂芬·格里森的男子去了霍巴特警察局，想要报告他在2009年1月26日晚上的所见所闻。格里森当时住在桑迪湾的车里，认识鲍勃和苏，
as he occasionally helped them with their dinghy. He expected that police would follow up with him to provide a statement, but they never did. Barbara Retter wanted to know why. She contacted the police and insisted they conduct a formal interview with Gleason. The police reluctantly agreed. Stephen Gleason told the interviewing officer that his friend, Paul Rowe, should be viewed with suspicion. Rowe lived on a boat which had been moored alongside the four winds on the night of Bob Chapel's disappearance, and he was known to invite homeless people aboard. A month prior to the four winds incident, Rowe had allegedly told Gleason that Bob Chapel was, quote, a condescending old cunt, and I'd like to rip his
因为他偶尔会帮他们处理小艇。他本以为警方会找他录口供，但他们从未这样做。芭芭拉·雷特想知道原因。她联系了警方，坚持要求他们对格里森进行正式讯问。警方勉强同意了。斯蒂芬·格里森告诉讯问警官，他的朋友保罗·罗应该被视为嫌疑人。罗住在一艘船上，鲍勃·查佩尔失踪当晚，这艘船就停泊在“四风号”旁边，而且众所周知，他经常邀请无家可归的人上船。在“四风号”事件发生前一个月，据称罗曾对格里森说，鲍勃·查佩尔是个“自以为是的混蛋，我想用一把旧钳子把他嘴里的
teeth out of his head with a pair of old pliers. Gleason claimed that he'd been sleeping in his car overlooking Sandy Bay on the night of January 26, 2009, when a homeless teenage girl knocked on his window. He suspected that she and her boyfriend had bordered the four winds, and might have something to do with Bob's disappearance. It was curious that Paul Rowe had never been questioned. After all, his boat was the closest one moored to the four winds on the night in question. Rowe also had a long criminal history which included serving prison time for stabbing a man. At the persistence of Sue's lawyer, police finally questioned him in 2012. Rowe denied knowing Sunil Fraser or Bob Chapel, but remembered the four winds because of its
牙齿一颗颗拔出来”。格里森声称，2009年1月26日晚，他睡在俯瞰桑迪湾的车里，当时一名无家可归的少女敲了他的车窗。他怀疑她和她的男朋友登上了“四风号”，可能与鲍勃的失踪有关。令人奇怪的是，保罗·罗从未受到过讯问。毕竟，在事发当晚，他的船是停泊在“四风号”最近的船只。罗还有过长期的犯罪记录，包括因刺伤他人而入狱。在苏的律师坚持下，警方终于在2012年讯问了他。罗否认认识苏尼尔·弗雷泽或鲍勃·查佩尔，但因为“四风号”的
distinct double mast. He admitted to having a violent temper that worsened when he was intoxicated, but denied having anything to do with Bob's disappearance or assisting Sue with the murder. He said he didn't know anyone named Megan Vass. According to Rowe, on the night of January 26, 2009, he had been drinking with Stephen Gleason before returning to his boat. Rowe claimed he kept his boat there until around November 2010. However, photographs taken during the investigation into Bob Chapel's disappearance proved otherwise. There was no sign of Paul Rowe's vessel in any of the images. In reality, Rowe had up and left the day after Bob's disappearance, relocating his
独特的双桅杆而记得它。他承认自己脾气暴躁，喝醉后会变本加厉，但否认与鲍勃的失踪有关，也否认协助苏谋杀。他说他不认识叫梅根·瓦斯的人。据罗说，2009年1月26日晚，他和斯蒂芬·格里森喝了酒，然后回到了自己的船上。罗声称他的船一直停在那里直到2010年11月左右。然而，在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪案调查期间拍摄的照片证明事实并非如此。在所有照片中都没有保罗·罗船只的踪迹。实际上，罗在鲍勃失踪后的第二天就收拾东西离开了，把他的
boat to Constitution Dock on the other side of the city. Police never queried this inconsistency. While the public remained divided about whether or not Sunil Fraser was guilty, her family and supporters continued to rally around her. They felt there were other possibilities that weren't explored due to investigators having cast their suspicions on Sue prematurely. What about Megan Vass's DNA? In the rare chance that Megan's DNA was walked on board by somebody else, it would have likely appeared in multiple places rather than in one single puddle. Furthermore, secondary transference of DNA is extremely rare and it would have been
船转移到了城市另一边的宪法码头。警方从未质疑过这一矛盾之处。虽然公众对于苏尼尔·弗雷泽是否有罪仍存在分歧，但她的家人和支持者继续支持她。他们认为，由于调查人员过早地将怀疑目标锁定在苏身上，导致其他可能性未被探索。那么梅根·瓦斯的DNA呢？如果梅根的DNA是由于某种罕见的偶然被其他人带上船的，它很可能会出现在多个地方，而不是单一的一滩。此外，DNA的二次转移极为罕见，而且在如此大的量下几乎是
nearly impossible in such a large amount. There were also some unidentified fingerprints and human hairs found on board the four winds that didn't belong to Sue. Then there was Bob's daughter, Lisa, who had spoken of her father coming to harm on the four winds the very night he disappeared. Despite this, Lisa wasn't questioned by police until four months into the investigation. There was also the issue of a police log recorded on January 27, 2009 that had been withheld from Sue's defense team and therefore not presented at her trial. The log stated that at some time between 7.45 and 8.30 on the night Bob went missing, a woman who lived in a large house overlooking Sandy Bay had looked out over the water.
不可能的。船上还发现了一些不属于苏的身份不明的指纹和人类毛发。还有鲍勃的女儿丽莎，她曾提到父亲在失踪当晚在“四风号”上遭遇了不幸。尽管如此，丽莎直到调查四个月后才被警方讯问。还有一个问题是2009年1月27日记录的一份警方日志，该日志对苏的辩护团队隐瞒了，因此未在审判中出示。日志称，在鲍勃失踪当晚7点45分到8点30分之间的某个时间，一位住在俯瞰桑迪湾大房子里的妇女曾向水面望去。
She'd seen an inflatable dinghy leaving the area where the four winds was moored. She believed the dinghy was being driven by a male aged between 40 and 50 years old with thick, wavy, reddish-brown hair and a, quote, weather-beaten sailor look. Underneath the woman's statement, a detective had written, Person fits description of Sue Niel Fraser. Witness was some distance from dinghy and presumed it was a male due to the way the dinghy was sitting low in the water at the rear. That comment was entirely subjective, yet investigators hadn't bothered looking into any other possibilities. In actuality, the woman might have in fact seen a male as she told police.
她看到一艘充气小艇离开了“四风号”停泊的区域。她认为驾驶小艇的是一名40到50岁的男性，留着浓密、波浪状的红棕色头发，看起来像个“饱经风霜的水手”。在那位妇女的陈述下方，一名侦探写道：“此人符合苏·尼尔·弗雷泽的特征。”目击者距离小艇有一段距离，并根据小艇尾部吃水较深的情况推测那是一名男性。这一评论完全是主观的，但调查人员并没有费心去调查任何其他可能性。实际上，那位妇女可能确实看到了她告诉警察的那名男性。
There had also been a report from a woman who lived on the foreshore who said she had heard a distressed male's voice in the middle of the night. Police had largely ignored this report, even though it could have been vital in identifying the timing of Bob's attack. Then there was the ongoing argument about Sue's drug smuggling theory. While Sue's trial was taking place, the Australian Federal Police seized 464 kilograms of cocaine with a street value of $160 million from a yacht in Brisbane. Three Australian men were arrested after law enforcement agencies in the United States tipped off Australian authorities. While the prosecution passed off Sue's drug smuggling concerns as
还有一份报告来自一位住在前滩的妇女，她说她在半夜听到了一名男子的求救声。警方基本上忽略了这份报告，尽管它对于确定鲍勃遇袭的时间可能至关重要。此外，关于苏的毒品走私理论的争论一直在持续。在苏受审期间，澳大利亚联邦警察在布里斯班的一艘游艇上查获了464公斤可卡因，黑市价值1.6亿美元。在美国执法机构向澳大利亚当局提供线索后，三名澳大利亚男子被捕。虽然检方将苏关于毒品走私的担忧斥为
ludicrous and unfounded, some argue that this bust showed the possibility wasn't without merit. During Sue's trial, the police had told the court there were no known break-ins to yachts in the Hobart area in the weeks leading up to Bob's disappearance. However, this wasn't true. Several locals had in fact had their dinghy stolen and boats broken into, but the police never followed up these reports in relation to Bob's disappearance. Instead, placing the blame on the local homeless population. On the night of Bob's disappearance, another vessel north of Sandy Bay had been ransacked in a similar manner to the Four Winds, with the power turned off at the switchboard and the alarm
荒谬且毫无根据，但一些人认为这次查获表明这种可能性并非空穴来风。在苏的审判期间，警方曾告诉法庭，在鲍勃失踪前的几周里，霍巴特地区没有已知的游艇入室盗窃案。然而，事实并非如此。事实上，几名当地人的小艇被盗，船只被闯入，但警方从未就鲍勃的失踪跟进这些报告。相反，他们将责任归咎于当地的无家可归者。在鲍勃失踪当晚，桑迪湾北部的另一艘船只也以类似于“四风号”的方式被洗劫，配电盘上的电源被切断，警报
system disengaged. With mounting pressure from Sue's supporters and various media outlets, the heat was on for the state coroner to announce a public inquest into Bob Chappell's death. But in January 2014, coroner Glenn Hay confirmed that there wouldn't be an inquest, as he supported the findings of Sue's murder trial and didn't believe anyone else had been involved. Coroner Hay believed a formal hearing would be a waste of court time and resources, while subjecting Bob and Sue's loved ones to unnecessary stress. Given that Sue had exhausted her appeal options, an inquest was her last chance to have the case reexamined. Then, almost two years later in November 2015, a new opportunity arose.
系统被解除。在苏的支持者和各媒体机构的压力下，州验尸官面临着宣布对鲍勃·查佩尔的死因进行公开调查的压力。但在2014年1月，验尸官格伦·海伊确认不会进行调查，因为他支持苏谋杀案的审判结果，并不认为还有其他人参与其中。海伊验尸官认为正式听证会是浪费法庭时间和资源，同时会给鲍勃和苏的亲人带来不必要的压力。鉴于苏已经用尽了上诉选择，调查是她重新审视案件的最后机会。然后，近两年后的2015年11月，一个新的机会出现了。
An amendment was made to the Tasmanian Criminal Code Act that allowed the right to appeal to the courts in circumstances where fresh and compelling evidence had become available. This meant Sue could launch another appeal, providing she could present evidence that was compelling enough to convince a judge for her appeal to be heard. Sue's supporters erected billboards in the centre of Hobart and along major roads, offering a $40,000 reward for anyone with quote, true facts that led to Sue's release. In 2016, former detective turned true crime writer Colin McLaren started investigating the Bob Chappell case himself.
塔斯马尼亚州《刑法法案》进行了一项修正，允许在出现新的、令人信服的证据的情况下向法院提出上诉。这意味着苏可以发起另一次上诉，前提是她能提供足以说服法官受理其上诉的令人信服的证据。苏的支持者在霍巴特市中心和主要道路旁竖起了广告牌，悬赏4万澳元给任何能提供“导致苏获释的真实事实”的人。2016年，前侦探转行的真实犯罪作家科林·麦克拉伦开始亲自调查鲍勃·查佩尔案。
He was convinced that Megan Vass held a vital clue to solving the mystery of what went down on the four winds that Australia Day. While Colin didn't think Megan killed Bob, perhaps she had been on the yacht that night and witnessed something terrible happen. By this point, Megan Vass was 23 years old and running with the motorcycle gang. Colin McLaren managed to track her down and she eventually agreed to speak to him in person. They met at a hotel in Hobart. Megan was accompanied by her boyfriend, with the counsellor on standby to provide support. Megan was visibly apprehensive. It was clear that she was highly stressed and on edge. She didn't want to talk,
他确信梅根·瓦斯掌握着解开那个澳大利亚日“四风号”上发生之事的关键线索。虽然科林不认为梅根杀了鲍勃，但也许她那天晚上在游艇上，目睹了可怕的事情发生。此时，梅根·瓦斯已经23岁，并与摩托车帮派混在一起。科林·麦克拉伦设法找到了她，她最终同意亲自与他交谈。他们在霍巴特的一家酒店见面。梅根由她的男朋友陪同，并有一名咨询师待命提供支持。梅根明显感到不安。很明显，她压力很大，处于紧张状态。她不想说话，
saying the whole situation had haunted her for 11 years, but her boyfriend urged her to. It wasn't your fault, he told her. Somebody did the wrong thing by you, you're the one carrying it all. Megan paced nervously around the room, unable to sit still. She then begged her boyfriend to let her leave. Colin McLaren urged her to think of Sunil Fraser, who was spending her elderly years in prison in a wheelchair. He told Megan how grateful Sue would be if she just told the truth. Distraught with her head in her hands, Megan responded, I know this and I've tried so hard. It's draining me for fuck's sake. I can't do it today.
说整个情况困扰了她11年，但她的男朋友敦促她开口。“这不是你的错，”他告诉她，“有人对你做了错事，你是那个承受一切的人。”梅根紧张地在房间里踱步，无法安静坐下。然后她恳求男朋友让她离开。科林·麦克拉伦敦促她想想苏尼尔·弗雷泽，她正在监狱里坐着轮椅度过晚年。他告诉梅根，如果她说出真相，苏会多么感激。梅根痛苦地双手抱头，回应道：“我知道这一点，我尝试过很多次。这让我精疲力竭，该死的。我今天做不到。”
Megan said she thought about Sue every single day, and that if she could, she would go and unlock her cell door herself. Unable to cope with the pressure of the situation, Megan ended the meeting. However, before leaving the hotel, she was presented with the statutory declaration that Colin McLaren had prepared in advance. It stated, I was on the four wins yacht on the night of Australia Day 2009. I was there with people that I won't name. I don't want to give any details except that I was on the yacht. The lady, Sunil Fraser, was not on the yacht. I have never met her. I don't know her. I just know she is in prison.
梅根说她每天都在想苏，如果可以的话，她会亲自去打开牢门。无法应对这种情况带来的压力，梅根结束了会面。然而，在离开酒店之前，她被出示了一份科林·麦克拉伦提前准备好的法定声明。声明写道：“2009年澳大利亚日那天晚上，我在‘四风号’游艇上。我和我不愿透露姓名的人在一起。我不想提供任何细节，除了我当时在游艇上。那位女士，苏尼尔·弗雷泽，当时不在游艇上。我从未见过她。我不认识她。我只知道她在监狱里。”
I don't want to say why I was on the yacht, and I don't want to say any more. Megan signed the document. The statutory declaration was given to the director of public prosecutions, but no further action was taken. Megan Vass's boyfriend was eventually charged with perverting the course of justice after police argued that he pressured her to sign it against her will. Sue's lawyer, Barbara Retta, remained committed to proving her client's innocence. There was another detail that had been bugging her. It related to the red yachting jacket belonging to Sue that was found on the Esplanade on the morning of Bob Chappell's disappearance.
“我不想说我为什么在游艇上，我也不想再多说了。”梅根签署了这份文件。这份法定声明被交给了公诉署，但没有采取进一步行动。梅根·瓦斯的男朋友最终被指控妨碍司法公正，因为警方辩称他强迫她在违背意愿的情况下签署了声明。苏的律师芭芭拉·雷特仍然致力于证明她当事人的清白。还有另一个细节一直困扰着她。它与苏的一件红色游艇夹克有关，这件夹克在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪那天早上在滨海大道上被发现。
When this item was forensically analyzed, a 26cm long, dark hair was found on it. However, the hair was never tested. Barbara urged the director of public prosecution to test it against the DNA database, and in April of 2017, they finally agreed. The hair did not belong to Sue. Instead, it was linked to a woman who had been taken into police custody at 8pm on January 27, 2009, the night after Bob Chappell's disappearance. Barbara Retta discovered that when police first found the jacket, it was thrown into the back of a police car without being properly bagged as evidence. The hair made its way onto the jacket when the woman was
当这件物品经过法医分析时，上面发现了一根26厘米长的深色头发。然而，这根头发从未被检测过。芭芭拉敦促公诉署将其与DNA数据库进行比对，2017年4月，他们终于同意了。这根头发不属于苏。相反，它与一名在2009年1月27日晚上8点（即鲍勃·查佩尔失踪后的第二天晚上）被警方拘留的妇女有关。芭芭拉·雷特发现，当警察最初发现这件夹克时，它被扔进了警车的后座，没有被妥善装袋作为证据。当那名妇女被带上车时，头发落在了夹克上，
taken in the car for reasons unrelated to the Bob Chappell investigation. Four days later, when an officer went to retrieve the jacket for forensic testing, he found it laying in the dirt in the police car park. During that time, the jacket had been exposed to both rain and sun, with many people passing it by. The police log submitted at Sue's trial had made no mention of this. Sue's legal team believed they'd amassed enough new information to finally present their case to the Supreme Court of Tasmania. They had the stat deck from Megan Vass, the witness statement from Stephen Gleason that named Paul Rowe, and various experts who were willing to weigh in on the elements of the investigation they believed were handled incorrectly.
原因与鲍勃·查佩尔的调查无关。四天后，当一名警官去取回夹克进行法医检测时，发现它躺在警察停车场的泥土里。在此期间，夹克既经受了雨淋又经历了日晒，许多人从它身边经过。苏受审时提交的警方日志对此只字未提。苏的法律团队认为他们已经积累了足够多的新信息，最终可以向塔斯马尼亚最高法院陈述他们的案件。他们有梅根·瓦斯的法定声明、斯蒂芬·格里森指名保罗·罗的证词，以及愿意就他们认为处理不当的调查要素发表意见的各种专家。
In October 2017, Sue began her leave to appeal with the aim of convincing the judge that there was enough new and compelling evidence to warrant a retrial. 19 witnesses were expected to take the stand over the course of the hearing, the first being Megan Vass. However, when Megan appeared in court, she retracted the statement made in her statutory declaration, saying it was, quote, not fucking true. She denied being on board the four wins on the night that Bob Chappell went missing and claimed that she had been pressured into signing the stat deck and offered payment to do so. Megan became aggressive, screaming, I had been made to sign that statement out of fear. I was threatened to be put in the boot of a car. She eventually ran from the courtroom
2017年10月，苏开始申请上诉，目的是说服法官有足够多新的、令人信服的证据来证明重审的必要性。预计在听证会期间将有19名证人出庭，第一位是梅根·瓦斯。然而，当梅根出现在法庭上时，她撤回了法定声明中的陈述，称其“他妈的根本不是真的”。她否认在鲍勃·查佩尔失踪当晚登上过“四风号”，并声称她是被迫签署法定声明的，并被许诺支付报酬。梅根变得咄咄逼人，尖叫道：“我是因为恐惧才被迫签署那份声明的。我被威胁要被塞进汽车后备箱。”她最终跑出了法庭，
to avoid the media waiting outside. Stephen Gleason had since been convicted of causing grievous bodily harm after repeatedly bashing his neighbour over the head with an iron and was currently serving nine years in prison. A lawyer acting on behalf of Colin McLaren had visited Gleason in prison and presented him with a photographic lineup to see if he could identify the teenager who knocked on his window on the night of Bob Chappell's disappearance. Gleason had singled out a photo of Megan Vass. However, because the lawyer had presented this lineup to Gleason without permission from law enforcement, police claimed that both the lawyer and Gleason were perverting the course of justice. They also believed that the lawyer had strongly
以避开在外面等候的媒体。斯蒂芬·格里森此后因多次用铁器猛击邻居头部而被判犯有造成严重身体伤害罪，目前正在服九年刑期。一名代表科林·麦克拉伦的律师在监狱里探访了格里森，并向他出示了一组照片，看他能否认出鲍勃·查佩尔失踪当晚敲他车窗的那个少年。格里森挑出了梅根·瓦斯的照片。然而，由于律师在未经执法部门许可的情况下向格里森出示了这组照片，警方声称律师和格里森都在妨碍司法公正。他们还认为律师强烈
influenced Gleason to identify Megan Vass. Both men were charged with interfering with Sue's appeal bid. Regardless at the hearing, Gleason maintained his belief that Paul Rowe was responsible for Bob's disappearance and maintained his identification of Megan Vass as the teenager who knocked on his car window on the night in question. To complicate matters further, Gleason also admitted he would lie to help Sue prove her innocence. The leave to appeal concluded on February 6, 2019, with the verdict to be delivered at a later date. Around this time, Colin McLaren published his findings in a book titled Southern Justice. A firm believer in Sue's innocence, the book sought to highlight the various mistakes made
影响了格里森去指认梅根·瓦斯。两人都被指控干扰苏的上诉申请。无论如何，在听证会上，格里森坚持认为保罗·罗应对鲍勃的失踪负责，并坚持他指认梅根·瓦斯就是事发当晚敲他车窗的那个少年的说法。更复杂的是，格里森还承认他会撒谎来帮助苏证明她的清白。上诉申请于2019年2月6日结束，判决将在晚些时候公布。大约在这个时候，科林·麦克拉伦在一本名为《南方正义》的书中发表了他的调查结果。作为苏清白的坚定信徒，这本书试图强调调查中犯下的各种错误。
the investigation. McLaren also teamed up with filmmaker E Vash to present their case for Sue's innocence in a six-part documentary series for the Channel 7 network, titled Undercurrent. Both the book and the series explained McLaren's theory as to how Bob Chapel was really murdered. He believed the more logical possibility was that two or more people broke into the four winds, not expecting to find Bob on board. Caught off guard, they killed him in the saloon and then attempted to let water into the yacht to destroy as much evidence as possible. Based on a length of rope that was found dangling from the rear entry hatch, the drops of blood on the lounge suite underneath and scuff marks above the lounge,
麦克拉伦还与电影制作人E·瓦什合作，在第七频道网络的一部名为《暗流》的六集纪录片系列中展示了苏清白的理由。书和系列片都解释了麦克拉伦关于鲍勃·查佩尔究竟是如何被谋杀的理论。他认为更合理的可能性是，两名或更多人闯入了“四风号”，没想到会在船上发现鲍勃。措手不及之下，他们在沙龙里杀了他，然后试图让水进入游艇以尽可能销毁证据。根据在后部入口舱口悬挂的一段绳子、下方休息室套件上的血滴以及休息室上方的擦痕，
McLaren theorized the attackers then tied a rope around Bob's body and pulled him out of the saloon via the skylight above. As McLaren explained in Southern Justice, the rope is visible in police photographs. Its presence teases the astute investigator. This clue is vital to understanding the crime scene and cannot be ignored. But it was. Elongated vertical blood drops are evident on the lounge, their shape indicating that at some point his body was above where the drops fell. This is Detective 101 stuff. Logically, I can see no other solution.
麦克拉伦推测袭击者随后在鲍勃的尸体上系了一根绳子，并通过上方的天窗将他从沙龙里拉了出来。正如麦克拉伦在《南方正义》中所解释的那样，绳子在警方照片中清晰可见。它的存在挑逗着敏锐的调查人员。这条线索对于理解犯罪现场至关重要，不容忽视。但它被忽视了。休息室上清晰可见拉长的垂直血滴，它们的形状表明在某个时刻他的尸体位于血滴落下的位置上方。这是侦探入门知识。从逻辑上讲，我看不到其他解决方案。
With the release of Southern Justice and the Undercurrent documentary series, Sunil Fraser's case was back in the spotlight. Channel 9's 60 Minutes secured an exclusive interview with Megan Vass, which promised viewers explosive revelations. The episode aired on March 10, 2019. Megan, now aged 25, was still tormented over a secret that had now haunted her for a decade. She became incredibly emotional as she began to reveal the whole truth of what happened on the night of January 26, 2009. Through tears, Megan claimed she and two other men whom she didn't
随着《南方正义》和《暗流》纪录片系列的发布，苏尼尔·弗雷泽的案件再次成为焦点。第九频道的《60分钟》获得了对梅根·瓦斯的独家采访，承诺向观众揭示爆炸性内幕。该集于2019年3月10日播出。现年25岁的梅根仍然被一个困扰了她十年的秘密所折磨。当她开始揭露2009年1月26日晚发生的全部真相时，她变得非常激动。泪流满面中，梅根声称她和另外两名她不想
want to name had been in the Sandy Bay area breaking into boats to steal money to buy alcohol. They entered the four winds thinking it would be vacant and were caught off guard when they found Bob on board. One of the men started arguing with Bob and the confrontation escalated. The man launched an attack that lasted for around 20 minutes, hitting Bob over the head multiple times with an unknown object. Megan said she urged the man to stop, but he was much bigger than her and she was helpless. The sight of the blood eventually caused her to vomit, likely accounting for the dinner plate sized DNA sample found on board, as well as the vomit stained rags and face washers.
透露姓名的男子一直在桑迪湾地区闯入船只，偷钱买酒。他们进入“四风号”时以为它是空的，当发现鲍勃在船上时，他们措手不及。其中一名男子开始与鲍勃争吵，冲突升级。该男子发动了持续约20分钟的袭击，用不明物体多次击打鲍勃的头部。梅根说她敦促那名男子停手，但他比她强壮得多，她无能为力。血腥的场面最终导致她呕吐，这很可能解释了船上发现的餐盘大小的DNA样本，以及沾有呕吐物的抹布和洗脸巾。
She refused to name either of the attackers or reveal what they did with Bob's body, but stated, quote, whatever's happened, it's been horrible. Megan explained it had taken her so long to speak up because she had been living a hard life on the streets and was afraid to come forward. When interviewer Liam Bartlett asked why people should believe her now, Megan responded, I don't have a good reason really. I'd like to see Sue home with her family. It's the right thing to do, I suppose. As to whether she would retract her story when put in front of the court again, Megan said, I can't give a legitimate reason as to why anyone should believe me,
她拒绝透露任何一名袭击者的姓名，也不愿透露他们如何处理鲍勃的尸体，但表示：“无论发生了什么，那都是可怕的。”梅根解释说，她之所以花了这么长时间才说出来，是因为她一直过着艰难的街头生活，不敢站出来。当采访者利亚姆·巴特利特问为什么人们现在应该相信她时，梅根回答说：“我真的没有一个好的理由。我想看到苏回家和家人团聚。我想这是正确的事情。”至于如果再次被带到法庭前她是否会撤回她的故事，梅根说：“我无法给出一个合理的理由说明为什么任何人应该相信我，”
and given my track record, yeah, maybe they shouldn't. But I'm here now and I'm doing all I can. I can't do anymore. The episode was banned in Tasmania due to Sue's pending application for appeal, but on March 14, 2019, Megan signed an affidavit confirming that she was on the four wins on the night of Bob Chappell's murder. This carried more power than the statutory declaration she had previously signed for Colin McLaren. In the affidavit, Megan named the two men she was with and said that they had accessed the four wins because there was no dinghy attached, leading them to believe it was unoccupied. She said she couldn't recall the events that transpired after the attack on Bob or how she got back to shore.
“考虑到我的过往记录，是的，也许他们不应该。但我现在在这里，我正在尽我所能。我不能再做更多了。”由于苏的上诉申请尚未审理，该集在塔斯马尼亚被禁播，但在2019年3月14日，梅根签署了一份宣誓书，确认她在鲍勃·查佩尔被谋杀当晚在“四风号”上。这比她之前为科林·麦克拉伦签署的法定声明更具效力。在宣誓书中，梅根点出了与她在一起的两名男子的名字，并表示他们进入“四风号”是因为没有系小艇，导致他们认为船上无人。她说她记不起鲍勃遇袭后发生的事情，也不记得她是如何回到岸上的。
One week later, a judge ruled there was enough fresh and compelling evidence to warrant Sunil Fraser's leave of appeal. This was excellent news for Sue. Since her arrest, she had missed the death of her mother and the births of four of her grandchildren. If her appeal was successful, it was possible that she could face a retrial or that her conviction would be overturned. If it failed, she would be able to apply for another leave of appeal only if further fresh and compelling evidence came to light. Outside the courthouse, Sue's daughter Sarah commented, This is just one step in what's going to be a very long journey for us as a family. She's an innocent woman and it's time she came home and was with her grandchildren for cuddles.
一周后，法官裁定有足够多新的、令人信服的证据来证明苏尼尔·弗雷泽的上诉申请是合理的。这对苏来说是个好消息。自被捕以来，她错过了母亲的去世和四个孙辈的出生。如果她的上诉成功，她可能会面临重审，或者她的定罪可能会被推翻。如果失败，她只有在出现进一步新的、令人信服的证据时，才能申请另一次上诉。在法院外，苏的女儿莎拉评论道：“对于我们作为一个家庭来说，这只是漫长旅程中的一步。她是一个无辜的女人，是时候让她回家和孙辈们拥抱了。”
I want my mum back. Sue's appeal was scheduled to commence at Hobart Supreme Court in late May 2020, however it was delayed due to the global COVID-19 pandemic. It finally took place at the start of March 2021, by which point Sue had been in prison for 11 and a half years. Megan Vass was the star witness for the defense. While Sue's lawyer acknowledged that Megan had been an unreliable witness and had changed her story several times over the years, they explained that the issue of her credibility was secondary to whether or not her DNA had arrived on the yacht by her being present on board. Sue's lawyer said, There is an anchor that is fixed and
“我想要回我的妈妈。”苏的上诉原定于2020年5月下旬在霍巴特最高法院开始，但由于全球新冠疫情而推迟。它最终在2021年3月初进行，此时苏已经在监狱里待了11年半。梅根·瓦斯是辩方的明星证人。虽然苏的律师承认梅根是一个不可靠的证人，多年来多次改变说法，但他们解释说，她可信度的问题次于她的DNA是否因她出现在船上而出现在游艇上。苏的律师说：“有一个锚是固定的，那就是
that is the finding of DNA of Megan Vass. If that anchor holds, it will produce a compelling case that there's been a miscarriage of justice. On day one, Megan appeared via video link, explaining she had recently overcome her drug addiction but remained mostly homeless. Once again, it was clear the situation caused her a great amount of stress. She became visibly emotional as she admitted to being on the four winds when Bob Chapel was murdered. It was the first time she'd made this admission before the courts. In a similar story to the one she gave to 60 Minutes, Megan said that she had been drinking in the suburb of Goodwood with her then-boyfriend and two of his friends, one of whom was Steven Gleason.
发现了梅根·瓦斯的DNA。如果这个锚稳固，它将产生一个令人信服的案例，证明存在司法不公。”第一天，梅根通过视频连线出庭，解释说她最近克服了毒瘾，但大部分时间仍然无家可归。再次显而易见，这种情况给她造成了巨大的压力。当她承认在鲍勃·查佩尔被谋杀时她在“四风号”上时，她明显变得情绪激动。这是她第一次在法庭上做出这种承认。在与她告诉《60分钟》的故事类似的故事中，梅根说她当时和当时的男朋友以及他的两个朋友在古德伍德郊区喝酒，其中一个是斯蒂芬·格里森。
This expanded on Steven Gleason's previous comments, in which he said Megan had just knocked on his car window at the beach. According to Megan, the men came up with a plan. They'd go to Sandy Bay and rob boats for more alcohol money. Megan hadn't been involved with the plan but went along with it because she was drunk. In Sandy Bay, they found a dinghy on the beach and used it to enter the four winds, not expecting to find anyone on board. When they encountered Bob Chapel, Megan said her boyfriend started, quote, flipping. He attacked Bob and it was the sight of blood that caused Megan to vomit. She couldn't recall anything that happened after that.
这扩展了斯蒂芬·格里森之前的评论，即梅根只是在海滩上敲了他的车窗。据梅根说，男人们想出了一个计划。他们去桑迪湾抢劫船只以获取更多的酒钱。梅根没有参与这个计划，但因为喝醉了就跟着去了。在桑迪湾，他们在海滩上发现了一艘小艇，并用它进入了“四风号”，没想到船上会有人。当他们遇到鲍勃·查佩尔时，梅根说她的男朋友开始“发疯”。他袭击了鲍勃，是血腥的场面导致梅根呕吐。在那之后发生的事情她什么都不记得了。
Things were looking promising for Sue, until Megan took the virtual witness stand again the following day for cross-examination. This time, Megan said she'd been mistaken when she said there were three men on the yacht, when in fact there were only two. She then changed her story again, saying there was only one man. Having caught her in a lie, the prosecutor asked Megan, you can't remember being on that boat, can you? Megan responded, no. She said she'd been harassed into giving evidence and that someone had threatened to harm her if she didn't provide one of the men's names she had given. It was a major blow for Sue's defense. They requested that Megan Vass be relieved as a witness and her testimony abandoned.
事情对苏来说看起来很有希望，直到第二天梅根再次出现在虚拟证人席上接受盘问。这一次，梅根说她在说游艇上有三名男子时弄错了，事实上只有两名。然后她又改变了说法，说只有一名男子。检方抓住了她的谎言，问梅根：“你不记得在船上，对吧？”梅根回答：“不。”她说她被骚扰才提供证据，如果她不提供其中一名男子的名字，有人威胁要伤害她。这对苏的辩护来说是一个重大打击。他们要求免除梅根·瓦斯的证人身份，并放弃她的证词。
Instead, they focused on what they saw as issues with the original trial, mainly the DNA evidence linked to Megan. A DNA expert for the defense had contradictory findings to the prosecution to prove that Megan's DNA couldn't have appeared on the four winds of via secondary transfer. They argued that if the jury heard from this expert, there would likely be enough to exonerate Sue on the basis of reasonable doubt. However, the prosecution explained that on the day the four winds was found sinking, it wasn't treated as a crime scene. It was eventually transferred to a marine facility in Goodwood, the same suburb where Megan Vass claimed to have been on January 26, 2009.
相反，他们专注于他们认为原审中存在的问题，主要是与梅根有关的DNA证据。辩方的一名DNA专家得出了与检方相反的结论，以证明梅根的DNA不可能通过二次转移出现在“四风号”上。他们辩称，如果陪审团听取了这位专家的意见，很可能足以在合理怀疑的基础上为苏开脱。然而，检方解释说，在发现“四风号”下沉的那天，它并没有被当作犯罪现场处理。它最终被转移到古德伍德的一个海洋设施，即梅根·瓦斯声称在2009年1月26日所在的同一个郊区。
At least 21 other people, including insurance assessors, police officers and civilians, had entered the yacht before forensic swabs were taken. Any one of these individuals could have transferred Megan's DNA on board. The prosecution concluded that it was highly unlikely that Megan Vass was involved in Bob's death, while there was, quote, overwhelming evidence that Sue Nielfrazer was. After five years in the making, the appeal came to an end after just two and a half days. Outside court, Sue's daughter Sarah said she was optimistic that the judges would realise that a miscarriage of justice had been served.
在进行法医拭子采样之前，至少有21个人，包括保险评估员、警官和平民，进入了游艇。这些人中的任何一个都可能将梅根的DNA带上船。检方总结说，梅根·瓦斯参与鲍勃死亡的可能性极小，而“有压倒性的证据”表明苏·尼尔·弗雷泽参与了。经过五年的准备，上诉在短短两天半后就结束了。法庭外，苏的女儿莎拉表示，她乐观地认为法官会意识到司法不公已经发生。
Sarah said, Mom is innocent and this needs to be rectified so that she can get out and be acquitted. The true perpetrators of this crime need to be held to account and justice achieved for the sake of Bob. For seven months, Sue and her supporters waited anxiously as a panel of three judges reached their decision. On November 30, 2021, the judge's announcement was finally handed down. While one judge accepted Sue's appeal and welcomed a retrial, the other two dismissed the appeal. With two against one, Sue had lost. Bob Chapel's family have remained tight lipped about the case over the years,
莎拉说：“妈妈是无辜的，这需要得到纠正，以便她能出来并被宣告无罪。这起犯罪的真正肇事者需要被追究责任，并为鲍勃实现正义。”七个月来，苏和她的支持者焦急地等待着三名法官小组做出决定。2021年11月30日，法官的公告终于下达。虽然一名法官接受了苏的上诉并欢迎重审，但另外两名法官驳回了上诉。二比一，苏输了。鲍勃·查佩尔的家人多年来对该案一直保持沉默，
while Nielfrazer's supporters remain unwavering in their belief that she is innocent. Among them is Stuart Tipple, the lawyer that helped exonerate Lindy Chamberlain, whose wrongful conviction was covered in episode 136 of Case File. Another lawyer has called the case against Sue the greatest miscarriage of justice in this country since Chamberlain. Sue's supporters have made numerous requests for a royal commission into Bob's disappearance to no avail. In January 2022, 13 years after Bob's presumed death, Sue lodged an application to appeal to the High Court over the dismissal of her case. It's unknown whether the court will consider her application.
而尼尔·弗雷泽的支持者仍然坚定地相信她是无辜的。其中包括斯图尔特·蒂普尔，他是帮助林迪·张伯伦平反的律师，其冤案在《案件档案》第136集中有所报道。另一位律师称针对苏的案件是自张伯伦案以来该国最大的司法不公。苏的支持者多次要求对鲍勃的失踪进行皇家调查，但无济于事。2022年1月，在鲍勃被推定死亡13年后，苏就其案件被驳回向高等法院提出上诉申请。目前尚不清楚法院是否会考虑她的申请。
Either way, Sue will be eligible for parole in August 2022. To Sue and her family, clearing her name is just as important as her freedom. The question of what really happened to Bob Chapel continues to polarise the Australian public. Some wonder if Bob had faked his own death. Others question if it were an accident. Perhaps the toilet water pipe broke and Bob injured himself trying to fix it, accounting for the blood on board. He might have then attempted to use the E-PURB to call for help before falling overboard and drowning. Others remain convinced of Sue Nill Fraser's guilt, noting her string of lies and a constantly changing story.
无论如何，苏将在2022年8月获得假释资格。对苏和她的家人来说，洗清她的名字和她的自由一样重要。关于鲍勃·查佩尔究竟发生了什么的问题继续使澳大利亚公众两极分化。有些人怀疑鲍勃是否伪造了自己的死亡。其他人质疑这是否是一场意外。也许厕所水管破裂，鲍勃在修理时受伤，这解释了船上的血迹。他可能随后试图使用E-PURB呼救，然后落水溺亡。其他人仍然确信苏·尼尔·弗雷泽有罪，指出她的一连串谎言和不断变化的故事。
Sue's incarceration has been viewed critically, not necessarily because people believe she is innocent, but because she shouldn't have been convicted on circumstantial evidence alone. Whatever the case, Bob Chapel's outcome remains unknown. The four wins were sold at public auction to one of the salvage agents who helped stop it from sinking. They planned to take its sailing once they retire, just as Bob and Sue had planned to do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
苏的监禁受到了批评，不一定是因为人们相信她是无辜的，而是因为她不应该仅凭间接证据就被定罪。无论情况如何，鲍勃·查佩尔的结局仍然未知。“四风号”被公开拍卖给了帮助阻止它下沉的打捞代理人之一。他们计划在退休后像鲍勃和苏计划的那样去航海。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。